thank you
thank you uh good evening and welcome to
this northwestern area planning
committee meeting uh
today wednesday the 16th of december
2020.
my name is councillor mrs maddie
thompson and i'm the chairman of this
committee
the meeting is held under regulations
which came into effect on the 4th of
april in response to the code of 19
pandemic
so there are a few housekeeping issues
just to run through
first of all could i please ask everyone
present in this meeting to ensure your
microphone remains muted and your video
feed off we're not addressing the
committee actually i thought we'd change
that but we haven't yet
this will reduce background noises and
avoid any unintentional disturbances
the meeting will be hosted remotely via
conferencing software
this allows members of the public to
attend virtually
and while being able to protect
themselves
and to observe the government doctor
measures
we're streaming this meeting live as
well as recording
and by being present in the meeting you
are giving your consent
to being recorded members and officers
during each item
please use the chat function of the
meeting to indicate if you wish to speak
and i will then invite you at the
appropriate time members are reminding
that apart from indicating you wish to
speak or that you have to
leave the meeting the chat function
should not be used for any other purpose
including questions because it's not
available to members of the public
when speaking and referring to the
agenda papers please ensure you
reference a page or paragraph number and
keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible
when invited to speak please ensure you
turn on your microphone
and your video please may i ask officers
taking part in the
meeting to introduce themselves starting
with mr lee please
good evening chairman um my name is
matthew lee and i am lead specialist
place and chief plan officer morton
district council thank you
thank you mr lee right mr johnson mr
johnson here
he's not here today chairman right okay
would that be mr lawrence
in his doing that role
or is he just sitting in he's just
viewing if he's just come back so just
get an idea of the community
hey how about miss sergeant
unfortunately she's unwell so uh i'm
working through my list here
sorry about this mrs i'm pretty sure i
did sushi here
good evening i'm hayley parker-haynes
and i'm a senior caseworker at morgan
district council
thank you thank you and miss balls
good evening i'm hannah bowles and i'm a
specialist in development management
lovely thank you and um
katie but it isn't coaches is it tara is
our committee clark
that's right chairman good evening it's
me at taraba community services officer
for the evening thank you
that's lovely um any other officers
present
um to take part in the meeting as
distinct from supporting nit
okay i'll take that as another one um so
could we please have a roll call of the
members
present committee members to start with
anyone attending in a minute thank you
uh yes chandler members when i call your
name if you could just confirm if you're
in attendance please
starting with councillor durham please
uh thank you chairman can you see and
hear me
thank you very much indeed and i'm here
thank you thank you
council mrs fleming president tara
thank you councillor jarvis
thank you thank you tara chairman
present
thank you councillor keys
good evening chairman good evening
members and people are witnessing i'm
present thank you tara
thank you chairman councillor morley
good evening everyone present
thank you councillor good evening tara
present
good thank you thank you council mrs
thompson's president councillor miss
white
i'm afraid everybody was here oh
wonderful thank you sir i was about to
give you an apology
in case you haven't made it home yet uh
thank you
and could i just ask if there's any
members in attendance please
hello tara yes i'm present counselor
penny channel
thank you
is that the only one
[Music]
thank you uh one thing i do have to
notice we've had an application
has been withdrawn and there was some
technical issues with it so
it will come back at another time and
that
one is number 20
slash 01021 um
i have to find that in a minute but i'm
sure there was a pure application you
were interested in you'll find that i'm
sorry about that this was a bit of a
last minute thing
um item three is the minute from the
18th of november the previous meeting
it's recommended the minutes of the
meeting being held on 18th of
november 2020 found on pages 9 to 12 are
approved as a pure and accurate record
iso move if you wish to second that
motion please
turn on your video and unmute and
spread your name
matters of accuracy can you please um
just indicate on the chat
um i'll take that as i know
um um
can we accept those by sent members if
if you don't agree please let me know
soon
so okay everyone
all agreed item four declarations of
interest i'm afraid i have to reach
out to disclose the existence and nature
of any disposable pecuniary interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-opportunity
interests relating to items of business
on the agenda having regard to
paragraphs six to eight inclusive of the
code of conduct for members
members are reminded they're also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware
shouldn't need a rise to the meeting if
any member has an interest
and just to declare please use the chat
function now to indicate
and i will ask you to speak
uh chair and counselor has indicated yes
i was just wondering where on the list
i've got to
council civil please thank you chairman
uh i'd like to declare a non-pecuniary
interest
as i am a resident of little tottenham
and also chairman of little tottenham
parish council
pertaining to a gender item number five
okay thank you very much anybody else
there's usually council dharma about now
yes i've i've actually got a golden hand
raised
chairman but um yes thank you a
non-pecuniary interest as a member of
essex county council
because they are statutory consultees on
various aspects of the planning process
thank you
thank you um i've got a very vague
non-pecuniary interest in that i
i know all sorts of people who are
speaking here this evening
but only through parish council um
work not through anything else so that
applies to the
gold hanger application and the
toll-free one
council keys did you want to say
something
yeah it's good even though we're just a
non-pecuniary i'll sit on great shots
from paris council one
yeah that's fine thank you that's lovely
thank you i think that
i think that's everyone um
right so we are moving on now to the
first
planning item which is item five on the
agenda it's
land south of beckham business park
beckingham street culture major
um and we do have a public speaker
which will
miss well we'll be doing this one
because it was my sergeant
yes right okay sorry i've got apparently
the chairman
can hardly hear anyone else who can't
hear
i think you're quite muffled apparently
chair oh
okay i can hear okay
i'm very sorry i'm sure yeah so can i i
can hear
i can hear you sorry that's to do with
youtube sorry it's youtube
it's for the public okay okay
um right the item is found
on pages 13 to 64.
um there is a members update circulated
um if anyone needs a minute to find that
and read it um
please let me know um
we we can have the report and then the
speakers and then i'll
move on to the recommendation and the
debate thank you
sorry thank you chair
so planning permission is sought for the
erection of 13 business and general
industrial units an office block and a
cafe
with related infrastructure including a
road parking spaces
drainage landscaping and an ecological
area
here we have the location plan and there
were previously
three large fruit washing drums on the
site um whilst the structures have been
removed the concrete faces remain in
place
here's an aerial view of the site and
the accent is taken from beckingham
street
and the development would utilize and
extend the existing
access track which serves beckingham
business park
through here
here is the block plan building a
which is along here and building b
are proposed to accommodate the
industrial units
building c which is here in the pink is
the proposed office block
and the cafe is located centrally in
this area here
and the land to the south west of the
site
will be utilized for ecological
mitigation and a drainage area
we have the proposed ground first floor
plans block a
which contains five of the industrial
units
and the proposed elevation and section
of block a
section
here we have the proposed ground floor
plan and section for block b
which would contain eight industrial
units
and the first floor plan for block b
and the proposed elevations for block b
here are the proposed floor roof and
section plans for
the proposed office block
and the proposed elevations for the
office block
then here are the proposed elevations
and floor plans for the cafe
we have a soft landscaping plan
you can see the areas of grass in green
and the landscaping plan continued to
show the area
to the south west of the site
we have the hard landscaping plan the
darker grey
is the access road and the lighter gray
the parking spaces
and the hard landscaping plan continued
and the only hard landscaping proposed
in the southwest area
is a pathway here
and then we have some sight photos
has he done it
and then we have some illustrative
photographs as well
the application site is a designated
employment site and an area
and the area which contains the proposed
built form is
allocated employment land the site is
located within the development boundary
of tulsa major
and the ecological mitigation and
drainage area
is supported by policy n2 of the ldp
therefore there's no objection to the
principle of the development
the proposed development is considered
to have an acceptable visual impact
would not detrimentally impact
residential amenity and no objection has
been raised in terms of access or
highway safety by the highway authority
the proposal would result in economic
benefits the locality and provide new
high quality employment units and
generate jobs
in line with policy e1 of the ldp as
well as the guidance contained within
the mppf
therefore the application is recommended
for approval
thank you chair thank you
right we have three public participants
for this planning application
um in line with the participation scheme
i
now invite an objector mr payne to read
out his submission
um may i remind everyone who's going to
be speaking that you are allowed
two minutes and i am very strict there
will be a timer in the background i'm
afraid
i don't think you'll be able to watch it
at the same time but
um i will give you a tiny bit of leeway
because the first will
any of us know about it is when the bell
goes at the end of the two minutes so
i'll probably let you finish a sentence
so mr payne if you're
ready um off
right thank you thank you maddie um i'd
like to object to this uh
planning application um i've lived in a
village for over 33 years
and although the business park uh
preceded my occupation
over that period has been a substantial
increase in numbers of vehicles
traveling to and from the business park
and the size of the lorries now
traveling on our country roads
is unsustainable as shown by the
condition of our roads
i also object for the following reasons
there are currently
we believe at least 16 vacant units in
the business park
if these were left then there would
already be a significant increase in
cars and worries on the local roads
which are already struggling to cope
with the amount of traffic to and from a
business park
another planning application for eight
units eight units has been submitted
so with 24 additional units being
utilized our roads would already be
overloaded
and to add a further 13 units an office
block and a cafe
with potentially over 100 employees what
we believe
make our roads dangerous at certain
times of the day
especially as much of our roads have no
pavement
there is clearly not sufficient appetite
for the business park
the scene from the vacant units
currently there and the recent
conversion of b1 units into four
residential flats
why build more the travel plan submitted
does not add up
apart from the tulsa major and little
tottenham pedestrians would not travel
to the business park
the local roads are not conducive to
cyclists and there's little evidence
that employees would travel to the
business path by bicycle
as there is no public transport this
leaves cars
and there is little evidence for car
sharing either
and considering a number of employee
cars that are now parked outside the
business park
instead of in their allocated parking
areas within the business park
we have little faith in the travel plan
being well policed by the business park
management
buckingham street has very recently been
resurfaced after many years
years of neglect
[Music]
just in case anyone noticed that we are
in fact on first name terms i'd like to
point out that mr payne is
chairman of the parish council and
therefore we've known each other for
some
number of years but um of late only
only through the parish council um so
thank you mr
payne and i'll now ask um mrs neath
who represents the parish council to
make her submissions
thank you chair
this site is for employment but that
does not mean any proposed development
provided employment must be approved
regardless of other policies
we believe this proposal is contrary to
policies as follows
it is not sustainable it would not
contribute to the vitality or health of
the community
nor would it protect or enhance the
village or natural environment
no future measures could make it
sustainable
s8 it would go outside of the settlement
boundary
the officer report says this is
acceptable for employment
but this local plan policy also says
that planning permission will only be
granted where the intrinsic character
and beauty of the countryside is not
impacted upon d1
the new buildings would be visible from
the surrounding area
giving an overly industrialized aspect
which would be detrimental to the visual
immunity and character of the
countryside
they would generate additional noise
light pollution and disturbance and
would do nothing to enhance the
distinctiveness of the local rural area
the 74 parking spaces do not meet the
vehicle parking standard requirements
for out-of-town non-residential
development
and would be insufficient an application
to the parking partnership for parking
restrictions
was recently refused so there is no
mitigation in place to prevent further
over spill parking within the village
d1 there would be around a hundred
additional cars coming to and from the
business park each day
the travel plan actions to minimise
single person car trips are not
deliverable
essex county council have said the
impact of additional traffic would not
be severe
and cannot recommend refusal however
they do say
the rural location of the site is such
that for the majority of journeys the
only practical option would be to use
the private car
this should be taken into consideration
by the local planning authority when
assessing the overall sustainability and
acceptability of the site
overall this proposal is not sustainable
is too big and too damaging to the
character and immunity of tolerance
major
and the local area thank thank you very
much
if i may say um right we have now
submission three which is from
mr loon who is the agent so mr moon and
we're ready when you are pleased hello
can you hear me
perfectly thank you i hope the others
can
right okay i'll begin um thank you
chairman and good evening members
you should have a letter from me dated
the 14th december
which sets out the key reasons why the
scheme should be supported
and i ask you to refer to this the
application proposes a fully detailed
commercial development upon brownfield
land
allocated within your adopted local plan
for employment purposes under policy e1
the principle of the proposed use which
also responds to evidenced need
is therefore acceptable in your
development plan terms
the scheme has followed a detailed
pre-application exercise in late 2018
with officers and local members account
has been taken
of the advice given and the application
is accompanied by a suite of
professional reports
the application has been properly
considered against a whole range of
technical issues and it's pleasing to
note there are no objections by any
technical consultees
this should give you reassurance that
the council's local plan allocation
can be delivered a key concern from
local objectives relates to traffic
in particular hgvs however the scheme
comprises an office block and mostly
small
industrial units the development does
not propose any storage or distribution
uses
nor would it be suited to large-scale
manufacturing and as such hdv
movements will be limited and traffic
will mainly comprise cars and vans
a travel plan has been prepared with a
view to encouraging
car sharing the 12 reduction and other
sustainable transport options
es6 highways do not raise objections on
highway safety grounds
and there's no technical evidence to
dispute this the development will
provide for many jobs and deliver
significant economic benefits for the
district supporting your economic
prosperity strategy
and your officers advise the proposal
complies with local plan policies
and therefore in line with the mppf's
presumption in favor of sustainable
development
the application should be approved
without delay
uh your support german uh and members is
therefore welcomed
thank you thank you very much
oh right members the recommendation is
that the planning application
should be approved would be approved uh
subject to the applicant entering to the
legal
agreement pursuant to section 106 et
cetera et cetera as you can read in your
um on your papers uh will anyone second
that
please we do need a secondary in order
to debate it it doesn't mean you're
obliged to vote for it
i'm okay to second that okay thank you
um right members um
i have oh yes sorry i've had a
a reminder about
the gender item 10 which is 20
slash 01021
land rear of hill barn rectory lane wood
and mortimer
has been withdrawn um i'm very sorry
about this it was a technical
thing um if anyone needs more
information
i can ask mr lee but it isn't going to
shed much light i'm afraid i don't think
and so i'm terribly sorry i'm very sorry
for the people who've attended and
obviously
if you'd like to stay out of interest
please do and
if not then i understand um
so once again apologies are there any
questions from
members on that
no okay right um i have a list of
speakers
um councillor siddal you're the war
member and or one of the ward members
and you called it in would you like so
would you like to start uh i'm not the
board member
i'm in the uh adjoining ward member so
it's under toleration
you are the ward member so no you did
call it
i'm actually going to wait until a
little later so so far i have council of
durham and councillor morley so um
councilman is the other member would you
like to go first or shall we
no that's fine okay council darwin
thank you thank you chairman chairman in
our
lives as uh councillors we get contacted
by our residents
on a wide number of occasions and a wide
number of
uh reasons and becky and business park
has been a substantial contributor to my
inbox
um over the last few years
uh and um and indeed i have spent
and i i can safely say several hours on
the telephone
to residents and other interested
parties over the last
uh two or three years now
i totally appreciate that
this application concords
with the local development plan
and it is a designated employment site
however i think i've been
provided over the years with
such a wide variety of
physical evidence photographs statements
etc
regarding parking on the roads adjacent
obstructions caused by vans uh and heavy
goods vehicles
and uh employ employees um
choosing to park on the road outside the
business park rather than in
the um in the designated places
and it is going to be for that very
reason to support the residents that
live around becky and business park
uh and to have to put up with the
anti-social parking
and have to put up with the increased
number of
hgvs which you know undoubtedly
will be using a business park and and
you can't rule out hgvs
coming to deliver to one of the smaller
units and that's how most stuff arrives
these days
i very much doubt they would all be
office space anyway
chairman um i am going to
move away from my current my normal
stance for supporting
everything in the local development plan
because i fear
that there are significant aspects of
this that need resolving to the local
resident
satisfaction before we allow any
increase
in the becky and business park uh so
it is for that reason subject to
anything i may hear in the next few
minutes
uh in in the debate that um i am minded
currently
uh to not support this application thank
you
thank you council and cassie
yes thank you thank you chad it was
exactly the same reasons
as councillor dome was saying my
concerns and i've had people contacting
me
was really about the the parking is
seems to be the main issue
in the road i don't know
how much extra parking there is going to
be well it's 70 cars was it i think
did they say um extra
capacity but yeah it's
it does seem to be the main well one of
them
well i would say the main issues parking
lot even outside
residential um properties there
so really to do with some more assurance
right of of sorting that out i would
have thought
thank you okay thank you
um i have several hands up but i'm
losing track of who's put their hand up
in what order i've definitely got
councillor civil next
but if you could use the chat i would be
very grateful because then i've got you
in the right order
but counselor civil you did and i have
you next so um
your time please thank you very much
chairman
the applicant has ensured that the
development is commercially viable
however they have not considered the
state sustainability
and suitability and the impact on the
villages and the countryside
the development will not comply with
policy s8 and will have an impact on the
character of the area
and his development impacting onto
greenbelt land
this policy also stipulates that the
countryside will be protected for its
landscape
as well as its intrinsic character and
beauty
the development due to its size and bulk
will have a negative impact on the
beauty of the countryside
in this part of tulsa major and the
views from little totten
it will take 30 years before any trees
planted will reduce this
impact as 5.9 stipulates
in terms of the document there are no
trees currently at the site
it is consciously policies n2 and d1 due
to the impact and scale of the design
this is especially relevant to blocks a
b and c
these buildings are imposing and will
have a negative impact
the design of the buildings are in
congress and do not fit with the
surroundings
the buildings have a visible impact due
to the nature of the spur design of the
layout
whoever decided in the first place that
this was part of the settlement boundary
really needs to look at things more
carefully in the future
this policy states that any new
development is visually attractive
responsive to local character this
development cannot
demonstrate it makes its policy
the silver grey walls as detailed in
on the site are inappropri appropriate
for a site built into fields
3.3 page 17 the officers agree with this
d2 stipulates that any development
minimizes all forms of possible
pollution
including air due to the increased
traffic through little totem and tolson
major
this application does not provide
measures that adequately address
appropriate avoidance and mitigation
t1 there are no sustainable transport
modes with existing roads already unsafe
and unsuitable
this will create a residual residual and
a cumulative impact on tulsa major and
little tottenham
there is no public transport to the
village there is no pedestrian access
possible
with tulsa major tolston deity or small
villages
there are no pathways linking the
villages and it would be impossible to
walk from the site from either tiptree
or molden
the nearest largest settlements it will
generate a significant amount of impact
and the roads of the city have not been
a great upgraded
the site is already unsustainable and
unsuitable
for a business park and this development
will just exacerbate the situation
t1 also stipulates that any new
development which is likely to generate
significant journeys
in terms of numbers and lengths should
be cited in locations that are well
served by public transport
as well as walking cycling routes if we
look at how an employee can get to the
site
for example via train from calvin or
whitson they take a bus
to tulsa darcy and then walk
or they get a bus from great braxton and
then walk two and a half miles
or they get a bus to haybridge and then
walk four miles
all the roads there are no pavements and
few strike strip lights
5.5.15 then stipulates that 16 vital
spaces are those who want to risk their
lives in that way
this is clearly impossible for this site
3.3.4 the applicant states that they
will
encourage car sharing sharing this would
possibly be feasible if it was one unit
and one organization that this site was
being developed for
however due to the number inside the
units this is totally improbable
there's absolutely no way this transport
policy can be complied with with under
implemented
over 1400 vehicles already travel
through the villages
250 of those are commercial hevs
the concern is not just hdvs it's also
their vans and cars
already we have to have traffic calming
police
and the community ranges from olden
conducting speed checks
with 130 more employees at this site
5.53 stipulates that there will be
additional 24 trips
that means there will be five people per
vehicle
5.4.5.4.4 then stipulates
that there are 75 parking spaces for up
to 130 employees
as we know the business part leads
already to be cars being parked in tulsa
major there are no pavements and it's
already causing issues
the applicant is incorrect that the
concern is just about
hgvs it is also about the cars that
travel
5 000 pound traveling monitoring plan is
the risery in terms of the impact
uh if the ownership and there are
several business and this particular
applicant has several business
if they were really concerned about the
traffic they would be
investing in traffic calming measures
for both tulsa major and little totten
3.3.4 highways have looked at the
village and of course
you are not going to see traffic
problems and congestions in tulsa major
highways need to take into account the
roads leading to the site
the route to the a12 via great braxton
is already congested
there are numerous accidents at the
junction of great platform park road
and colchester road at peak times
at that junction an apple foot bridge
there is traffic stretching 400 meters
already
this is unsuitable and unsustainable
devon and it cannot be
approved members need to take into
account the views of the residents of
the three villages
most drastically affected and refuse
this application the growth of this
site is not sustainable is not well
designed and has contributed policies s1
t1 d2 and
n2 thank you thank you council
um right i have councillor white and
councillor
jarvis um i'm not sure
exactly of the order so can we go with
councillors councillor whiteford please
um counselor darren by the way i i have
a hand is that a legacy hand or are you
[Music]
um i have to say that um i think between
a rock and a hard place on this one
it's um in the ldp as a site for
development for business
um the problems with the lorries and the
roads have been there
certainly since i've been elected um but
because it's in the plan to have
development there
i don't think we can refuse this i i
just think you know we're going to know
where
the only thing i might suggest is that
it could be deferred until we get a
detailed report on the parking because i
am concerned that's my only concern
is that there is not enough parking to
support the units because that's
paramount because you'll only get the
people working in the units but you will
get the visitors other than that i
approve of the development i think the
design works
it's no more of an eyesore than the new
um sainsbury's at woodland fairers and
that we've all got used to fairly
quickly
um the only thing i have a slight
problem is and it's not a bit woolly on
the case law
is under 3.3.5 the little totum
water recycling center um it's saying
that it's at capacity
but due to recent case law and long
established um
legal arguments um this cannot be used
for a refusal but what i would say is
is there any way we can tie it up that
work cannot be started until the
recycling center is upgraded because
this
could very well take many many many
years
before this application's even started
so i don't know if the officers can
assist on those two points
that sounds like one for mr lee to me
and mr lee are you able to help us with
that
german do you want to come back at all
of them at the end all the points
that would be fine um councillor jarvis
then please
thank you chairman um my comments
are similar to councillor civils but but
not as detailed and as well researched i
i fear
i haven't i have read obviously the the
brief i have listened to what parish
commentary has been i i think clearly
uh from an employment point of view it
is a designated site etc
but it's all a question of uh balance as
we know each application on its own
merits and it's quite clear that the uh
it seems to me that the harm to the
countryside uh is significant
and it's quite clear that the harm
regarding traffic whether that is
increasing htv or whether that's just
cars and the number of uh
transports because of course people go
to sites and then they go home they
might go somewhere else for lunch that
sort of thing i know there's some
catering on site
but it's not just always a trip in and a
trip home so i think harm to the
country's side the traffic issues
quite i've lived in little tottenham
myself so i mean i'm familiar with the
site familiar with the issues
and so uh we we without going on further
because other councils have made the
points
more eloquently than i'm doing in this
case i would not be in favor of the
application thank you chad
thank you do any have any other
speakers waiting councilman
is waiting to speak oh right sorry
thank you chair a question for the
officers uh mr payne in his submission
referred to
b-1 units on the site being converted
into four residential flats i just
hoping to get some more information
about that from
the officers thank you
okay i'm sure we can do that i remember
that it was one of the
committed development conversions
um right it's actually my turn i think
finally so i
will have a question for that shortly mr
lee um
nearly everything i was going to say has
been said i'm speaking now as world
member not as chairman um i
do have concerns for all the local
residents particularly the ones opposite
obviously because you look at that row
of cars and you think well that's not so
bad well that's all right if you're just
driving past it that if you're trying to
get in hgb
vehicle in or out of the entrance
to the business park in that direction
or indeed trying to get
fairly large you've got even a
family-sized car out of one of the
residents is opposite
it becomes a problem and you end up
driving
um i
there is no way as miss councillor white
says there is no way of getting around
the fact that it's
in the ldp as an employment land but
i think there's so much wrong with this
particular application
that i am really struggling to support
it so
could i ask you mr lee to come back with
them
um answers to some of these many
questions
thank you chairman yes i was just trying
to look up something in relation to
councillor white's point um
i think uh councillor white summed it up
pretty well to be honest um
and i'll uh but i will obviously deal
with it because it's been raised by a
number of members
um as everyone present knows a planning
application
needs to be determined in accordance
with the development plan unless
material considerations indicate
otherwise
and that always needs to be our first
consideration when
us as decision makers whether it's
officers doing delegates or the
committee members or even the plan
inspector
look to make a decision on an
application um
as i've said before at committee uh you
know one of the things i like about
planning is it's 50
subjective and 50 um
um playing by the rules planning strong
parameters and that is
really the starting point is that 50 of
not
being subjective we have policies and
that is what we need to consider against
our application or consider applications
against they're adopted policies by the
council they're not
the planning authorities policies
they're not officers policies they're
not
the old councillors that were here you
know when the
document went through eight years ago
they are the council's policies and they
are the starting point for any
determination of any application that we
have in front of us
and as council drivers said each
application must be based on its own
merit and that is correct
but they still need to be assessed
against the adopted policies that are
relevant
to the application so you need to
consider
if they're already conflicting issues
with the policies that
it's different rather than just saying
you don't agree with the policies
as has been explained and discussed by
members and when within the offices
report
the application is an allocated site it
has been
looked at as part of the ldp process
considered that expanding
the beckon business park is a correct
and appropriate way to deliver
the employment need for the district
over the life of the plan which is until
2029
and i know uh members may have concerns
in relation to various things and i
highlight that
sorry no members race a lot of the
issues that raised related to maybe
existing problems
uh decorum of potential users of the
site and existing site
the planning system isn't here to solve
existing problems
you need to be able to deal with issues
that are raised solely from this
application
and while i can understand frustrations
with the public
may have in relation to people not
parking where they should be barking on
the matter such as that that isn't
really something for consideration as
part of this application
um this the existing site as is
is what it is and but the council has
considered it appropriate to expand the
site
and deliver employment land on that site
and as part of that process
of adopting the ldp issues such as
highways
would have been looked into and would
have been
considered and so the general highways
issues would have been looked at
when this site was adopted so raising
general
concerns i would say would be a very big
concern i would have towards looking to
for a reason for refusal because firstly
strategically it's been looked at and
found to be accepted in highways terms
but more importantly and specifically to
this application there has been a uh
transport assessment submitted which has
been actually looked at by the
essex county council highways and that
hasn't been objected to or conflicted
with by them so
i would have concerns in relation to
that matter and that will
sleep in relation to the allocation i
think some of the concerns relations
design and loss of countryside
seem to be going almost the principle of
redeveloping this site
and i would guide members away from a
reason future based on that because
this is an allocated site this
development of this site has been
exceptionally principal
and there will be general impacts on the
character area from
such a development similar to basic
similar
conversation we have about when it's
been reserved as an outline it's not
saying that designer
can't be looked at at this stage but the
principle of losing this field
is not something we can look at as an
issue because it has been is an adopted
site
um for clarity the council doesn't have
green belt we're not a green
uh metropolitan rebel district so
members can shy away from using that
phrase because it's not correct for
malden district council
um and seth is within the settlement
boundary so
that's the sort of consideration we have
you know whether you agree with it or
not
it is the adopted policy it is what the
council's agreed so
that would be a consideration for any
inspector
um related car parking i think
the officer report deals with it and i
was looking at it
but i've moved away so i think off the
cuff i think
our policy our adopted spd requires 74
car parking spaces
and the proposed development provides 75
so
actually in relation to washing its own
face the car parking vision
on this site in our adopted policy it
would meet that
um i haven't heard any evidence
specifically why
there would be a reason to consider it
needed larger
or greater level of car parking
understand the concerns about
the sustainability of the site but as i
said before as an allocated site
we would have considered that at that
time
in relation to council white point um
as members were aware reason for refusal
based on
sewage set raphael walter et cetera
is not something we can robustly defend
appeal um
case law explains that it's a matter
that should be looked at
through conditions and case law is very
clear that if a
condition can be imposed an application
shouldn't be refused
um and it should be dealt with through a
condition
and i understand there is a condition
imposed on the uh
it really recommended not imposed
recommended i think it's condition
25 um and i think if members look at the
member
update and the applicant has challenged
the
necessity for that condition because of
um arguably because they consider that
the site's allocated so it shouldn't be
a matter for the decision
saying that they don't makers with that
and they are recommending that condition
is
retained and imposed um the only other
point i think
in relation to um prior approval
um yes i can confirm a prior approval
has been granted
that though is not a planning
application it's not looked at
through our policies and the government
have facilitated
the allowance of the loss of some
employment
barnes you know we probably have to put
a little bit more use to them
district rather than the employment land
i think it's about 2015 this was looked
at
so um it was a little while ago um
unfortunately they aren't planning
applications we don't
have the same controls over them they
are more of a tick box exercise but
that really wouldn't be a consideration
for determination of this application
thank you chairman thank you
all right i have counsellor
thank you thank you chairman and and i
hear what mr mr lee has said and i've
listened to
what the other members say and
and um members will note that i'm
usually
um vocally in favor of supporting the
ldp
and mr leah said that we're obliged to
do that and i accept
unless there are material considerations
i believe that the misery that the
people living adjacent to the entrance
of the site
they've they have had several years of
misery due to anti-social parking by
um by staff on the site
who are not following the rules in
respect of
parking in allocated bays and other
service lorries
i've had photographs sent to me of an
obstruction of an ambulance
and and i think that the i would be
unhappy
about agreeing an application to extend
this site
in the absence of some mitigation
measures
to make the immediate neighbors lives
more tolerable
members will also know there is actually
a pending
local highways panel um
case which is on hold subject to
tonight's
tonight's decision and it would
certainly be something
um should this be granted tonight that
we can take back to
southeast parking partnership south
essex parking partnership
but uh chairman i i'm going to maintain
strongly that the inconvenience put to
the locals
and the the people living in the
vicinity
is a material consideration justifying
um refusal
thank you thank you um we will need to
be careful as mr lee pointed out
that you know existing problems are not
something we can expect planning
applications to solve so
you need to think about how we're going
to work that
counselor so uh
counselor keys please i wish to speak
right um everybody else is out of sight
well i think um councillor siddal had a
very good
um speech and i think if anybody can
come up with any reasons
i think mr siddal was able to come up
with a few of them if we can help him
with him or if he could
start it off i would be much appreciated
i know you and councilman morley award
members but
uh mr siddall did have a good chat i
think we can all agree with that he's
good speech not a chat
he's had an yeah lot of time that has
taken him to do that as a credit
to him for what he's come up with but
yeah if that's okay with you mr signal
well hang on a minute well we need to
have a vote first
you need to have a vote on the
recommendation and i don't think i have
to be mystic make to work out how
but we do have to do it the
recommendation to
refuse is on the table
and it was seconded yes it was i think
that was councillor miss white
so um those in
favor please tara could you please take
the roll call
oh yes can i just clarify this is this
is the officer's recommendation we are
voting yes i'll put
yes i'll put that on the table that's
what we're debating it's the officer's
recommendation to refuse so
depending on what happens with that
sorry to approve
to approve yeah
as we said the officer's recommendation
for approval
if you could just advise if you're a for
against rob staining when i call your
name please
starting with councillor durham i'm
against
thank you very much mrs fleming against
tara
[Music]
thank you council keys
uh i'm against thank you councilman
morley
against thank you councillor
against thank you council mrs thompson
again thank you and council miss white
well we should be voting for because we
didn't see ldp but there's actually a
point that might as well vote against
like everybody else has but it's
we're going to lose that appeal thank
you very much so chairman the results of
that are
nobody's for eight against and nobody is
staining thank you very much
so now members we need an alternative
proposal this time i'll get it right i
will
take a presumption that this is going to
be a
proposal to refuse but we need the
reasons for refusal
before we put that to the vote so can i
ask you council seal because you've put
a lot of work into this
i i i can chairman thank you
so i i would suggest that uh we
recommend refusal on policy eight
as it has an impact on the character
and area and impacting on the
uh landscape and its intrinsic character
and beauty
due to its size and bulk i'll say in
terms
of n2 and d1 due to the
impact and scale and density
of the design of the development and the
density
is a crucial thing and that is what part
of
the problem uh i would also suggest
this is a new development so that's the
crucial thing in terms of
t1 is the other buildings
were all built or all there before the
ldtp
this is a new development after the ldp
has been developed or implemented
and t1 of our in ldp stipulates
that there has to be sustainable
transport modes
and that uh or is it
that any new development which is likely
to generate
significant journeys in terms of numbers
and lengths
should be cited in a location that is
served by public
transport this site is not
served by public transport
so if the developer wants to you know
bring a bus service in
that serves little tottenham tulsa maze
that would be extremely welcome to
reduce the number of traffic
but there is no public transport and
this is a
new development okay let me go to mr
lee to get some professional advice on
the best way to put this please mr lee
thank you chairman um i think
the first point put forward by
councillor
siddal was really a bit of a two-parter
um talking about the impact on the
intrinsic character
and beauty of the area and
is a concern um the scheme is
the site is allocated for development
and that concern and that issue raised
by council seems to really go
just to the principle of developing the
site for um
for employment one of the time please
sorry
sorry i was just going to ask something
there's a second part of
that which then seemed to be more
specific to a
to the point about the actual appearance
of the
and the quantum for one of a better
phrase of the redevelopment of the site
and that also would go to some of the
points that councillor sydal raised when
he was speaking earlier about the design
which if members consider that the
actual appearance of the structures
and the quantum of development is uh
unattractive
and unacceptable and there's harm in
that way that is different to maybe some
of the
points that were maybe talk about
intrinsic character beauty because
that's about protecting the countryside
and
we've got to accept that this site
through the ldp can be built on
so trying to protect it's a field would
be a
very flawed approach especially when an
inspector was to look at it
but obviously due if it moves on to the
subjectivity points
that is something that's decision makers
um
would have potentially some legitimacy
in a reasonable view i'm not going to be
successful but would at least have some
legitimacy and a reason for refusal
in relation to the need for the location
to preserve by public transport the big
issue i would have just have to
highlight is this isn't an
allocated site we've accepted that this
site can be built on
for employment uses as part of the ldp
and any concerns in relation to the
sustainability of the site
would be a concern the comment in
relation to efficient maybe a bus route
or something like that
is that any section 106 contributions
need to be proportionate to development
and a scheme of this size would not be
expected to deliver something
like that and never would have been
through the allocation of the ldp for
that reason
um and obviously it doesn't form any of
the idp or other requirements for the
ltp for that reason
so i would have quite a lot of concerns
in relation to that second
concern that was raised by council
siddha thank you chairman thank you and
council said
i'm going to let you come back but we do
have to bear in mind not to check the
kitchen sink at it
because you can actually lose costs on
an appeal that you
you win because they don't like your
reasons
the the big difference between this
particular site is the fact that
um because of the spur element so with
the rest of the
rest of the business park does not stick
out
into the countryside like this is going
to so therefore it will have
an impact on the on the countryside for
both tulsa major
and little tottenham it's not screened
and it will take a long time for it to
be screened the buildings
are going to be silvery blue which on a
green field
you're going to see for a very long way
and it is extremely dense in terms of
the way that it's been designed
there's a there's an awful lot of units
and
yeah and and there seems to be too many
units and not enough parking space i
don't know
the the officers are saying that it's
within the limit
well that we know that we know that all
industrial estates never have enough
parking spaces
every single one i go to has problems
with car parking
and we are just making we are
exacerbating the situation for toll ship
major
with this new development so i think in
terms of scale
and density and its impact i think
they're all extremely
extremely valid i still would like t1
in there on transport because it's not a
sustainable location
this place has evolved it's not
something then
that originally it was a canning factory
and it's involved into this monstrosity
now
in terms of its development in terms of
the businesses in terms of the impact
it should never it should never become
what it's become
but that's another matter that's another
matter that's another story right
uh while you carry on thinking for a
minute i've got councillor white
and then i think we need a proposal so
if you can
narrow that down a bit that's what the
council
is like yeah thank you benjamin i mean i
just wanted to raise whether we could do
something with the parking and it was
just literally on the design aspect
because of the parking i mean
i i don't think we can do it on t1
because it is an allocated site
um but but i do wonder if we i don't
need to be successful but we could try
on design
and maybe link parking into that design
but that's the only reason i think we
can use
that sounds very sensible to me um mr
lee any thoughts
thank you chairman um as members will be
awake and you know i'm sure
councilwoman's been
committed to discuss these matters
obviously the level of car parking and
hard standing obviously can form a
reasonable refusal that fits in with
design
the only issue i'd raise with this
application is that
the level of the quantum of development
the level of car parking required
to a certain sense is what it is um
i personally don't think the provision
is particularly
poor in aesthetic terms in relation to
what the proposed use is
so i wouldn't want to use that as a sole
reason for you so if members considered
the excessive car parking landscaping
etc fed into a rather general
design that would be acceptable my
professional advice would be but
i don't think you could have a reason in
relation to design a car parking and i
don't think
you know council white's suggestion
would really go to deal with the point
that council siddha was trying to raise
either which is
you know which he expanded on further by
saying it's in relation to
a level of car parking provision on site
um
thank you chairman okay thank you um
right councillor siddha i'm sure you're
ready or very nearly ready with the
proposal
um i'm trying my best
would you consider you know
trying to limit your proposal to the
more subjective
elements and then possibly
with a final agreement delegated
to me as chairman and board member
councillor morley as chairman and ward
member
mr lee and yourself as the proposal okay
say whatever you're about to tell me
okay so
i would go back to that uh this
development
does not comply with policy s8 and will
have a
impact on the character of the area it
is contrary to policies
n2 and d1 due to the impact
and scale of the design and it will not
fit within its surroundings yeah and
the density of the scale and density of
the design
okay nobody can argue with scale
it's
the fact that they're proposing that
there's going to be 130 employees and
their 75 parking spaces
is immediately
it it cut it it's too difficult i hear
what you're saying but it fits the
standard
so i think as you outlined it sounds
certainly like a sensible proposal if
that's your proposal based on
those are the reasons for refusal um
will you also add any particular
conditions into
a delegated matter to be agreed uh yeah
i'm happy to do that
yeah because we're going to get a
terrible model if we're trying to do
that now we might easily miss something
else
yeah so we have council siddal's
proposal as
i hope you've been able to follow all
right members
i don't have a second one happy to
second happy to second that
counsellor right that was seconded by
well all sorts of people but
loudest and first of all so
um tara could you please
take the vote and i will get it right
this time on councillor civil's proposal
to refuse
based on the policies he's mentioned
and the actual wording to be
worked out in um
there's a word i'm looking for it and
i've lost it
to be
the board delegated the chairman which
is actually only two of us
and actually the council of civil
because it's his proposal
right members
and thank you chairman so members if you
could just indicate thought against or
abstaining
this is again as count as the chairman
just said voting uh
for refusal of this application starting
with counselor durham please
i'm for the proposal tara thank you very
much councillor mrs fleming
four thank you councillor jarvis
thank you councillor keys
uh four tara that's the morally
thank you council mrs thompson oh
thank you and council miss white abstain
sharing the results of that are seven
four nobody against and one abstention
thank you very much
okay thank you very much members um
right we are gonna have to move things
along a bit um now i've been very
generous with letting
everyone speak on that because it is so
very important to a small a small
village
um but we will move on now to
item six on the agenda which is our
second planning application
barnes at lower farm blind lane tolls of
the knights
so this is um there is a member's update
in relation to this
and it's this is parker haynes to
present please
thank you chairman planning permission
is sought to convert the existing
agricultural bars to a dwelling
it should be noted that there is an
extent permission to allow for the
conversion under a recent prior approval
application
twenty zero zero three nine eight the
main alterations under this application
from the prior approval
are the demolition and rebuild of barn a
change in external materials and slight
alterations to the design of the
dwelling and openings
this is the location plan
this is the block plan and the proposal
does involve all four barns so a b and c
a b c and d but he's a reference
these are the existing elevations of
bonds a b and c
these are the proposed elevations
advance a b and c
the existing and proposed elevations of
bondi
floor plan
the proposed floor plan barn a is the
um only aspect of the first floor
and these are comparisons the prior
approval elevations
and the proposed elevations the subject
of this application
and bonding these are some photographs
the site is existing
the proposed development has been
assessed against all material planning
considerations
including the previous permission whilst
the site is located outside of the
settlement boundary the previous
permission in this instance provides a
full
full back position for the provision of
a dwelling on this site
and therefore it is considered that the
provision of one dwelling in this
location is acceptable
this application is recommended for
approval thank you chairman
thank you thank you mr holmes um
in fact there's no one to speak on this
so i'm going to put the recommendation
that the
application be approved subject to the
conditions as detailed in the report
um can i have a second please i'll
second it second
thanks
okay um councilman and i are the ward
members i am also a member of the parish
council
who were not entirely happy about the
design
shall we say everybody um however
bearing in mind the fallback position
um unless i hear anything to the country
from other members before we get to the
vote i'm
really minded to support it um
anybody else wish to speak
oh i have counsellor fleming has had to
leave the meeting just in case anyone
[Music]
needs to be aware of that
right members there's no requirement to
speak but
if you want to please um pop up a hand
kelsey morley
no counselor's dramas degree officer
recommendation
okay do we need to take a vote does
anyone
feel strongly that against this council
jarvis
you know i'm sorry i was just going to
talk on it just for the benefit of
having some debate
um looked to me like a good design
and i was in favor of the officer's
recommendation
okay thank you don't worry there's
plenty of time
to want to talk about lots of things
um
counselor more are you trying to speak
or are you
is it just if you're picking
[Music]
i would rather do it that way so we are
voting on the
officer's recommendation to approve as
laid out in the offices report
thank you thank you um members if you
could just indicate four against or
abstain please
and starting with councillor durham
please four
thank you council mrs fleming oh sorry
she's looking for
two apologies and counselor jarvis
paul thank you tom thank you councillor
keys
four
four thank you chairman that's seven
four nobody against no abstentions thank
you very much
thank you so um that has been approved
in line with the officer's report and
recommendation right now we have agenda
item seven
which is bones by church street
tollsbury
um right let's have
the presentation please that's ms bowles
i believe thank you
thank you chair planning permission is
sought for the conversion renovation
and extension to a historic barn to
create a two-bedroom dwelling
here is the location plan you can see
the subject barn here
we have the proposed block plan and you
can see the access to the site will be
taken through the farm yard
and through an existing access point
we have the existing and the proposed
southern elevation
the form of the existing bomb will be
largely retained
with two modest single-story extensions
proposed on the north and the west
elevation
um one of which you can see here this is
the western extension have this six
the existing and proposed northern
elevation
again the form is largely retained and
the northern elevation
uh the northern extension story is here
we have the existing and proposed
east and west elevations
the existing and proposed ground floor
plans
again the proposed extensions are here
on the western elevation
and here on the northern elevation
the existing and proposed first floor
plans
and the proposed mezzanine level
we also have existing and proposed
section drawings
we have some site photos which shows the
current condition
of the listed building
and the top pictures here
show the the barn and the neighbouring
dwelling to the south
and then this is a view um facing west
from
the site
the proposed development would secure
the sympathetic restoration
and future of a vulnerable heritage
asset which has been on the at-risk
register for 16
years which this is a material
consideration of considerable weight
the council is on our sorry the council
is unable to demonstrate a five-year
housing land supply
and taking this into account the
location of the site for residential
development
is considered to be acceptable the
provision of a two-bedroom
dwelling would also contribute to the
council's housing stocks
the resulting dwelling is not considered
to adversely impact the neighboring
occupiers of the site
or or highway safety and parking
provision and i mean
and the parking provision and the means
of the area would be provided in
accordance with the recommended
standards
therefore the application is recommended
for approval thank you chair
thank you um right we do have
um we do have a submission from an
objective of objectives unfortunately
not able to make it i
have used my discretion to although it's
not strictly speaking technical issues
um i am going to ask mr lee to read it
out
if you would like parker
okay um yeah if you could just start
um i would start at the second paragraph
because the first bit was
um was more about
department and communication and a few
other things and not actually the
material planning
matters does that make sense to you mr
parker
yes thank you okay well when you're
ready um please
everybody note this is not the office's
view she is reading it on behalf of an
injector who wouldn't make it thank you
bo huntsville is a grade 2 listed house
which in the past has been the principal
dwelling in this farm steed but is now
our home
the buyer was split from the hall when
sold by the applicant if for our
information the buyer will overlook our
home
our garden our principal entrance door
and our every movement as we are coming
and going
causing a significant loss of privacy
and our neighbours in the beau
hans manor farm steve would also suffer
increased traffic movement that i'm
overlooking
it's our opinion this application is yet
another clinical attempt to exploit this
building for the maximum commercial
return as possible
a strategy that has been going on for
too long
numerous applications have been rejected
before and even her majesty planning
inspectorate
has previously rejected an application
this application for a two-bedroom barn
is yet again another piece in this
jigsaw and would clearly become a
four-bedroom home as the footprint and
the design allows
knowing the districts need two bedroom
homes they have used this as a hook
this shows the cynicism of the
application when clearly the modern
needs two bed starter homes or two bed
bungalows not large two bed barn
conversions with gyms
if it was the heritage of the structure
that they cared for this building would
not have been left to rot being on the
buildings at risk registered
should bring consequences for owners
allowing the neglect to continue
as the toll brief tullesbury parish
council concluded in their rejection of
the application the application is full
of holes with missing documents
incorrect plans the bare minimum in the
way of supporting evidence
and no consideration for the adjacent
homes or the wildlife in the area
including bats and birds of prey
there are two magnificent horse
chestnuts on our boundary that are
protected by their location in the
carthage of this listed building but
they could be lost during the renovation
due to root damage
which would expose bowhuntsville still
further the report
to the director of service delivery is
written in such a way to leave the
committee to the conclusion that
approval was the only outcome that the
whole tone of the report is heading only
one way towards a presumption for
approval
when surely the committee needs an
unbiased review of the application
there are no pros and cons of the
application only positives and the
concerns of the neighbouring homes and
the opinion of the parish council seem
to have been ignored
thank you well done it it was quite a
long one um
we can't know which bits mr bart would
have edited but unfortunately he's had
to
leave that to us um there is in fact no
board member because councillor
bamford has resigned um council morley
and i are the next best thing
and council morley has asked to speak
first so um
where you go councilman
um thank you jeff yes my concern with
this really is
um quite honestly building through a
farm yard like that with
machinery health and safety and various
things like that
and and i think it will impact a privacy
would be completely taken away there but
my my concern really is kevin i'm sorry
we have
we have the agent to speak i'm so sorry
councilman
um we don't have this we don't have the
submissions bird
what happened
and chairman she um this is the agent um
miss brown and she did some apologies
and she did apply to speak and we do
normally ask that they've provided a
copy of their statement
which we haven't got but she is on the
call and wanting to speak to him
right i can see him and i'm sorry i
missed that miss brown i apologize
um yes you have two minutes from when
you're ready and where are you going
thank you bones fire has stood for
nearly 200 years
the building has been on maldives at
risk register since 2004
having now been empty for over 20 years
the fabric has deteriorated
over time almost 10 years ago planning
was refused for its conversion and the
building is in a further state of
disrepair
over the last two years we have been
working on a scheme for the buyer
working in detail with barry hillman
krauts to produce a proposal that
preserves the historic frame and
respects the aesthetic
or architecturally agricultural
aesthetic of the original building
the proposal uses traditional
sustainable materials and allows the
historic frame to
remain exposed and protected internally
the new building envelope will encase
and protect the historic fabric with an
insulated breathable jacket the scheme
under consideration this evening has
been supported by the planning officer
conservation officer highways and
ecologists
presenting a sympathetic financially
viable proposal which will allow this
building to stand and be used for
another 200 years
the level of investment required to save
a building
such as this makes residential
conversion the most viable use
the objections to the conversion of the
builder building are historic
and local and are concerned with the
loss of an agricultural use
of which there is a vast over over
supply in the district
if approved the bar the buyer will
become a two bedroom home that is
flanked by existing dwellings to its
east
and west sitting comfortably within a
residential
and agricultural setting thank you
thank you all right i do apologize for
that i'll back to you councilman
please yeah thank you chair um
it's still though access to a farm which
um being a farmer myself it's it's not
really an ideal situation to be honest
with you and
i just think with health and safety and
vehicles running through a farm yard
i'm just not really sure about that
thank you
thank you i'm council jarvis i'll have
you next
thank you chairman um yes i've listened
with interest there's what the agent was
saying and obviously counselor morley
um of course uh it would be a great idea
to
renovate the bar i don't think anyone's
going to disagree with that it does look
in a bad state
um but um and of course we
there is a requirement at the moment to
increase
housing stock but that doesn't
necessarily mean that we have to convert
this bond to a house
i mean if you could get up again uh if
the officer could get up again the map
so we could see where the house is i'd
just like to
have another look at that is that okay
chairman yes please if we could do that
um the web is in charge of sharing the
screen
i think the point which i'm hoping to
just highlight is uh the point counselor
molly's referring to
is that i think we the agent just
mentioned and uh i need to be careful
because i know the agent hasn't got the
right to reply but the
agent sort of pointed out that it's
going to be you know sort of either side
of um
two other sort of uh properties sitting
uh neatly
but this is a farm this is a farm with
farmyard buildings all around it
and essentially this development here
which i think
is put up as two bedroom but it's a very
large
plot it looks to me two bedrooms but
this this this will be a property that's
essentially sitting in sitting in a farm
yard it just doesn't seem to me
um a very good idea
now i'm also trying to try to look at
that from a sort of planning point of
view of course
but in principle from a common sense
point of view it doesn't seem
a good idea in terms of where it is um
but i'm thinking to myself well at the
moment uh
you know there's a historic barn um and
although it's clearly in
a poor state and it certainly does need
to be
repaired nobody's disputing that um
more properties there i would feel uh
would be you know harm to the
countryside and i think
in terms of planning law that's what i'd
associate it with so
it doesn't look to me as if it's in the
right place it does i think there will
be lots of problems in terms of
traveling through the farm yard although
i noted the fact that there is
uh historical access permission to do
that
um but it it doesn't look to me like a
very
sensible use of the bar and what a pity
it can't be renovated
in some way as a historic bomb which is
its original
purpose so now i i generally not
really at the moment in favor but i'm
very happy to listen to other counselors
chairman
thank you thank you um i have
council civil next i'm saving my peace
at the end i think
council civil plea thank you chairman uh
sorry could we have the map back up
again sorry about that
[Music]
i'll just well i'll start talking i
haven't been to the scene i missed that
council case council said i'll get
to get to council occasionally okay so i
i have been to that site um
i i was there at that site uh sort of
during 2019 for for various reasons and
in terms of being a farmyard he's not
really a farmyard
and the two buildings that are on the
left-hand side
sort of sort of to of the diagram yep
right where your your mouse is thanks
thank you very excellent work
um those are also houses
um and in in terms of yeah there's
further houses on the other side of the
barn
there's a house to the left-hand side
which you can just see the name of it
um so there is a quite a lot of
residential
dwellings there already and it's not
exactly a farm in the
from from what i remember from going
there in the true sense of the word
and i think this particular development
will enhance the
that location so i i'm in favor
thank you thank you keys i'm sorry about
that
right oh good evening i've i've got a
few questions here i'm gonna
come at these with wearing two hats it
was a fuse on re
appeal what is the difference between
this
and the appeal i'd like to know
now i haven't been there for a few years
but i have been through there
in another job where i run the haulage
to collect stuff
not from the farm but that was a working
farm
now there was animals in the sheds to
the left as you went through
i know that and then with animals i know
this
is away from the people that are putting
the application
now animals make noises and their smells
and if i recall the yard naturally
slopes
towards this barn
that is up for conversion the land drops
away towards that
also if it's a crop assured
farm yard and i know this is the only
farmyard and
i would imagine their crop assured which
i think everybody nowadays has to be
crop assured to sell
um their goods to um the industries that
use them for food production
there would be a chemical store now
whether that
can be bought up i don't know where that
is situated and i don't
know what it is or how it is or anything
about it but there would have to be a
chemical store there for a bit of farmer
short
and i think counts uh cancer sydney
councillor morley
machinery is huge nowadays
and children and people walking about
where agriculture machinery is moving
about
is a no-go and i was through there
probably 15 sorts of years ago
now these conquer trees stroke horse
chestnut trees which i believe they were
were very very big well very very big
yeah they were very big then
now will they be disrupted
in the alterations of this building i
know it was mentioned earlier by one of
the other members
and also what about contamination
because obviously
it's been a farmyard for
forever i would imagine so i they're
just a few
things that would like to see and also
some pictures of the overview
when the barn is done is there any
pictures of
overlooking the other properties there
and the
distances i can't seem to see that on
there but that
that's sort of the gist of what i'm
trying to get at
close thank you um
mr lee or whichever officer is going to
answer that please glue chairman i will
come back on a number of the points but
it might
be worth it sorry ms bowles takes uh
members through the impact on the
neighbors using the plans first
okay yes let's start there thanks
oh sorry i'll just share the plans
thank you
so the closest neighboring property to
the application site is
is bowens hall here um at its closest
point which is corner to corner it's 25
meters um
as it sets out in my report
um the back-to-back distance contained
within the modern
district design guide in relation to
overlooking
is 25 meters and that's directly
back-to-back so
window to window obviously the
orientation of these
dwellings in relation to each other um
mitigate
any overlooking even
even further than if it was directly
back to back
um whilst then there may be some views
into the front part of the application
site this area wouldn't be class
private amenity space and therefore it
has it has been concluded that there's
no
um impact in terms of overlooking
um the access in relation to the farm
yard
and the um and the vehicular movements
obviously if this was an agricultural
barn there'd be
um additional um
agricultural vehicle movements uh
so as a residential dwelling it's not
considered to
worth that um thank you chair
okay thank you um mr lee bearing in mind
uh would you like me to speak first
actually mr lee
yep more than happy for that thank you
um i've actually got a lot of problems
with this and some of it's to do with
lack of
information like the arboreal report on
the trees that we don't know anything
about
and one or two things haven't been
mentioned and
i'm afraid some of it you'll have to
take my word for it but i do think it
it indicates that we don't have enough
information so this farm is under
natural england's high-level stewardship
which means it provides grassland which
has
uh has to be managed by grazing animals
but is there sort of for the benefit of
the brent east specifically and lots of
other wildlife
in general um which means
yes councilman keys was right that there
are animals
and they do make noises and they do
smell
and what goes in mustang afraid come out
um and in actual fact the farmer is
looking to increase because he's
increasing the grazing for the
work with natural england he's looking
to increase his
livestock and did in fact say to me that
he has been asking to use that bar
he would like to take the barn on as an
agricultural farm
again you can only take this as hearsay
but
i am concerned i i wish there'd been
some attempt to market the barn um
yes there may be a um a circuit of barns
in malden district but if you have cows
in church road in
toll free it's no good having spare
barns in
tulsa darcy you need the bomb where you
are
and i'm also very concerned that this is
no
two bedroom dwelling this is not a nice
affordable home in the in the sense that
someone
who is looking out for looking for a
two-bedroom home can in fact afford to
buy it because that's not what we're
looking at here you wouldn't need all
those extensions for that
the barn just the barn itself is more
than sufficient for a two-bedroom home
um so yes um mr lee can you come back
and help me with any
any of that and the other member's
question
thank you chairman um always happy to
help best i can
relation to councillor keys point
um about the people's approval
council it's lovely to see you in
attendance but would you mind
turning your video off please in your
microphone
thank you very much thank you good to
see you as always
um please please
but i'm very easily confused you members
know that um
officers report um deals with the matter
of
the previous appeal um the council
looked to refuse it
at the time for two reasons refusal
and when the inspector dismissed the
appeal which he did do
the major issue related to the impact on
the
listed building in relation to the loss
of special historic character and
architectural importance
that development was significantly
different in design and appearance and
scale see what the one is before us so
um that is obviously materially
different so
that the previous reason future falls
away because it is a very significantly
different proposal to what we have in
front of us
tonight um impacts the neighbors has
been dealt with by
um as bowls already
the point raised in relation to trying
to bet word smells
um existing uh cultural use etc
is a bit of an interesting point
obviously
the use of an adjoining site is a
consideration determination of the
application um i think there's
just support you know he's quite light
touch on this to a certain extent but
that's
primarily in relation to the
relatively light touch approach by the
playing agent
you know i think on an assessment that
officers considered like plant
authorities to take into account the
existing residential properties in close
proximity
there is unlikely to be a significant
harm but there is
limited information to support that
assessment so members had grave concerns
about that
and obviously the potential for the
impact on the existing business
that would be something that they may
wish to consider but
as i said it is quite a light approach
in the current application but officers
take into account the existing
properties you know it's quite a
balanced decision um
relation to councillor charles's point
about new dwelling yes we do need new
dwellings but as members know
it's not a case of just accepting any
dwelling um
so i don't disagree with his point in
relation to that
and you know you'll probably be hearing
me say things along those lines many
times over the coming months in
committees especially
the lack of five-year land supply but
that is obviously i think this is the
first northwest we've had
since not having a five-year lance plc
that is uh does slightly change the
balancing process but
it doesn't mean we automatically have to
accept any
new dwelling um the point about
marketing and sort of similar
points about certain other aspects of
um one of the things we have to consider
is the optimum
uh viable use and for a list of building
and what's interesting about that is
that doesn't mean it has to be the most
financially viable it's or the most
financially
generating the biggest profit for
anything it's about
the balancing process about what is the
right use for that building so there
normally would need to be some
part of the calculation wouldn't be just
financial um
officers obviously looked through that
aspect and that is um
within the office's report trying to
call out what's in
section 5.3 um because obviously that's
what our policy requires and that is
consistent with
government guidance and advice um
obviously there is a viability statement
with the
application um
the account of some you know the
officers recommending that that
they accept that this is the optimum
viable use but obviously if members
don't consider
that is because they think that the
reuse of the site
has a bomb if there is options it has
been marked etc hasn't been fully or
robustly
challenged obviously that is a
consideration for the termination of
this
application um just simulations to
dwelling point
um i can understand members sentiment in
relation to
the scale and everything else but
there's two things to think about one is
well three things but one is that our
policy doesn't
say it has to be a small property or it
has to be below a certain value
it only talks about number of bedrooms
but what you've also got to think is
that this is also about
the need to facilitate facilitate
people downsizing as well so it
shouldn't be assumed that
just because it's a two-bedroom property
it should only be looked at as a
entrance to the market dwelling there
may well be people who've
you know got quite well off you know got
valuable properties that maybe we should
actually downsize so
and our policy obviously doesn't require
it to be a relatively cheap
property and i think that would be why
because actually it facilitates churn in
the market
um in relation to the gym aspect what
i'd like to tell is
generally the rule of thumb that
planning officers take and you know we
do as a
as an authority probably because of the
last six years at least because i've
been here is
if that room is at the ground floor we
would consider that
the proposed use is probably what
they're likely to be using it's less
likely to be on the balance probability
to be used as a bedroom um the current
pros or frozen two bedrooms at first
floor so i think it'd be
difficult for us to potentially argue
that this was a three-bedroom property
as a reasonable person looking at the
plans would just look at it and see
two bedrooms upstairs um in relation to
councillor keith's points in relation to
trees and contamination
i don't think officers have any um
issues or concerns in either of those
points but
it would not be unreasonable to impose
uh two
fairly light touch conditions in
relation to either of those matters
um if members were to approve this
scheme so
in relation to protecting the trees and
in relation to
um if any contamination was found
present
so i think if members wish to we could
impose those conditions i think
hopefully i've covered all the points
thank you chairman um yes i think so mr
lee although
i think the point about downsizing
normally requires
to place you downsized to be smaller
than where you are
would it not no it's not my idea of
downsizing but
i hear what you're saying and i wouldn't
probably propose that as part of a
reason for a refusal but
um does any other member wish to speak
otherwise i um
when you develop my recommendation
which i haven't actually put yet come to
think about it
so for the sake of completeness
let us put the recommendation which is
in fact
to approve do i have a secondary for
that
i'll second that count uh chairman
you're still okay
to be seconded um
right members um i think we need to vote
sorry check just before maybe these
with or without uh the council of keys
easy points in relation to the suggested
additional conditions i put forward
i don't know how the committee thinks i
would say i'm going to add those as an
amendment
for this recommender for the purposes of
this recommendation members
um i think that would
be reasonable i can't think of anyone
who would add to that as a condition to
this recommendation
so can we vote on the recommendation to
approve please
thank you chairman thank you members um
so uh
the proposal is for approval of the
planning commission
and granting listing building consent
and with the additional two conditions
as mentioned
and members if you could just indicate
fought against abstaining please when i
call your name
starting with cancer durham please
i'm actually against the recommendation
thank you thank you
cancer jarvis against
thank you council keys
against councilman morley
against that's the siddha
four thank you councillor mrs thompson
again council miss white
four thank you chairman the results of
that are two
four five against and no abstentions
thank you very much
okay thank you um so that recommendation
falls so we need another proposal which
i'm
tempted to do from the chair unless
anyone else wishes to come forward with
something but
um go ahead chairman please do thank you
i would like to propose that we
refuse and my reasons for refusal would
be
lacking information on
alternative uses for the original use
and certainly on the lack of an arboreal
report
um for concerns about the future of the
adjoining
business should this go ahead um
mr lee can i have any thoughts on those
in the wording of them
um dear chairman obviously i think the
arabic
culturalist issue was something that we
could
deal with um for conditions so i
wouldn't necessarily
recommend that we put that on as a
reason for refusal
the matter in relation to the other
points
um i think they're all valid planning
reasons and obviously
as always obviously we've heard the
debate and
officers would look to construct the
reasons reviews were around those points
thank you or what council jarvis would
like to speak but i would actually say i
think the health
the health and safety aspects in the
farm yard you know we look to have
people walking and cycling into the
village
where possible it's certainly feasible
in terms of distance
whether it's safe is another matter um
but i think it's location next to a
working farm we are
consistently
yeah that's yep don't have an issue like
it's a balanced
opinion if that's what the committee
thinks it's well within the gift yeah
thank you council dramas please yeah
sorry chairman
i was just trying to help come up with
some some reasons
i think when obviously he was talking
earlier
he was talking about optimal use and i
think he was sort of suggesting that
there could be
uh more pursuit of uh perhaps an optimal
use
i.e being used by the farm as a bar and
i i sort of
read that he might be suggesting that
that more could be done in that area i
don't know whether that
whether any of that constitutes a reason
perhaps um
perhaps mattley could um advise us on
that
i think so yes that's what i was driving
up
mr lee yep thank you chairman um
i wouldn't suggest oh i wouldn't say i
was suggesting that as a
reason for reviews so um obviously the
lpa considers that you know it's look to
that and has found itself
but if members think that there could be
further expansion obviously you know
there's
so i'm sure members have familiarized
themselves with the salient point on the
file and obviously it's covered within
the office report so if members think
that you know it wasn't maybe as fully
robustly dealt with as could have been
or
all options haven't been fully explored
that would be a planning reason for
refusal yes
thank you chairman okay right thank you
thank you
that's my planning reason for refusal i
think options haven't
been fully explored i have concerns
about any impact
on the business given that the business
is potentially
and indeed does create a nuisance
because animals have to be housed in the
winter
think the fact that it's next to the
yeah farmyard is inappropriate on health
and safety issues
and apparently we can't use the trees
chairman for a bit of um advice what i
would say is that maybe rather than
being reasons for refusal in the
traditional sense i would advise it'd be
lack of
evidence to demonstrate um because
you know there's concern there's a
reasonable planning concerns and there's
limited information to allay those so
rather than saying definitively there is
a problem it would be
more of a lack of evidence to ensure
there isn't reason
concerns thank you right that's my
proposal members there is lack of
evidence to address these concerns and i
think
there is we need more evidence and
further consideration
do i have a secondary yeah i'll second
that
yeah right too late
right um could we have a vote please
yes of course chairman um so members
voting for um refusal
and as indicated by the chairman if you
could just um
advise if you're for against or
abstaining when i call your name please
starting with counselor durham
thank you very much councillor uh jarvis
author thank you councillor keys
for tara thank you councillor morley
thank you very much councillor siddall
against
thank you council mrs thompson
councillor miss white
results of that are six four one against
and nobody staining thank you chairman
okay thank you um right and again i will
actually get the wording
for the reasons for the refusal in
consultation with the
with me the ward members the german and
officers right
moving on and we are going to have to
speed up um so that's down to me too
i'm afraid um item eight on the agenda
is 19 blind lane gold hanger
where we have
just the one submission which is from
parish councillor and we have
um mr born who's the parish council
chairman who's going to read that
so could we have the presentation please
like comment
below
thank you chair so planning permission
is sought for a double garage with a
room within the roof space to the front
of the existing dwelling
we've got the location plan
and the block plan you can see the
location of the proposed garage
outlined in red here
we have the proposed elevations of the
garage
and then we have the proposed elevations
in relation to the house
you see the garage here and here
and again here from the side
here we've got the proposed floor plan
the proposed roof plan
and then some site photographs the
proposed garage would be located
approximately here in this photo here in
this photo
and here in this photo
um with a ridge height of 5.95 meters
which exceeds the eaves of the existing
dwelling
the um the garage is considered to have
a significant visual impact
the proposed development would result in
a visually prominent addition to the sci
and street scene which would dominate
the frontage of the site and form an
an incongruous development within the
street scene
the applicant's personal circumstances
have been taken into account however the
weight
attributed to this does not outweigh the
identified harm
therefore this application is
recommended for approval uh sorry for a
refusal
thank you to her god it's not just me
thank you
um right um this is born i'm sorry you
had to wait quite a while are you
are you ready yes i'm
here hopefully you can see me oh we can
hear you we can oh yes i can see you as
well now so
you have um two minutes please from when
you're good evening
chair and councillors i'm julia bourne
from gold hanger parish
council um as well as the council i'm
representing the applicant who is rather
nervous to speak
in this environment i'm hoping all the
other
councillors have read the letter
my support my statement is as follows
the parish council want to support this
proposed application the proposed garage
does sit in the front garden on the
north of the property
and doesn't impact the neighbour's light
the aesthetics of the build will match
the property
and there is precedent with number one
blind lane which also has a garage in
the front of the property
the other blind lane properties are
pebble dash rendered
local authority and some ex-local
authority
housing and it is not considered the
general
street scene is impacted adversely
by this garage and roof room
blind lane is a single track low traffic
road
and there isn't any visibility issues
the parents need the additional space
for their severely autistic son
as well as their other son who lives at
home and daughter and her family who
have had to move back to the parents
home
who have suffered financial difficulties
during the kobe pandemic
the letter found by the family describes
the current difficulties
and the positive impact that approval
would have on the seven
family members living in this house the
particular family circumstances should
be considered
under ldp policy 12 health and
well-being section
819 support development of healthy
communities
also the committee should consider
section 825 which states any
planning potentially detrimental to
health needs an accompanying health
impact assessment i would consider the
refusal
of this application would create a
situation that is detrimental
to the health of the occupants the
application
the applicants are one of four
households
from the same family living in the
village a gold hangar
there are four wells's in in the village
and the community is a very important
element of our village life
and the nppf section 8 is about
promoting healthy and safe communities
and this application aims to keep
families together in a self
safe healthy community thank you for
your time
thank you
um mr
lee sorry we have an issue with not
voting on the
i thought we took the two together
mr lee miss bird sorry chairman
um we took the two items together but i
think we discussed clearly planning
policy reasons and voted on the planning
application
i'm not sure we actually dealt with the
lbc but obviously maybe we'll need to
revisit after this item
we'll revisit after this item i don't
want to interrupt the flow
if i can help it so thank you very much
mrs dawn um
so i will put the recommendation which
is to review
so is that seconded
i'll second that chairman thank you
councilman siddall
um you know as always i point out just
because you said it doesn't oblige you
to vote
for it it's it's a matter of form which
is a puzzle to a lot of people who
aren't used to this and i quite
understand that puzzle um
so mems all right we have councillor
jarvis to speak uh councillor morley and
i are the board members
but i'm happy to go last so councillor
jarvis please
thank you chairman um i just wondered if
um um
obviously could sort of comment um with
regards to how much to the personal
circumstances we are supposed to take
into account because i'm sure none of us
uh none of us would hesitate to see that
there are
special personal circumstances but i
know that historically we've always been
told
that we aren't supposed to take those
into account so i'd like his guidance on
that please i've obviously heard uh
what the lady eloquently uh went through
there with from the parish point of view
regarding the health points and i think
i need some guidance from
officer lee thank you chair okay thank
you mr lee
thank you chairman um this section is
obvious this is dealt with within the
office report i think it's under the
other
um other material considerations rather
matters section um
the westminster case law is clear that
special circumstances of an applicant
can be a material consideration
determination of an application
but that has been further developed and
it's
clear that um special circumstances
should really be very special it's
um most of us have some level of special
circumstances we would put forward
and what this needs to be something that
is well above and beyond the normal
situation
um and in most instances uh personal
circumstances of the applicant our
material situation in very limited way
in the determination of a planning
application
and unfortunately planning is a
was our judicial process um and
so certainly we do need to remove our
personal feelings from
termination of applications which can be
very difficult
but i think that is something that we do
have to do as decision makers
you know we have to look at the long one
of the reasons for that obviously is the
planning is not is based on land it's
not based on an applicant
it's because we have to look at the long
term because we have to look at the life
the development rather than
um five or ten years that can be you
know 100 plus years or something um
i think that's as i said the office
report does cover that probably a bit
more eloquently than i've just tried to
do that um but it does talk about
you know the office support says whilst
the lpa is sympathetic to the need of
the applicant and his family there is a
need to consider the application against
the development plan
as material situations indicate
otherwise in this instance the
information provided by the applicant is
limited
and has not provided a detailed
rationale behind the need of development
or why other alternatives such as
attached single-story structure
would not be provided to the rear so i
would not not be invited
or why the garage is needed and have
been included and therefore is not
considered the personal service of the
applicant
outweighs the conflict with the
council's adopted policies
um as as you know obviously been
highlighted by him as well as when
taking through the presentation the
application is both for a garage and
development above it and obviously that
two-story development at the front
is visual it's considered to be quite
bulky by the lpa and quite dominant you
know and
yeah i said personal style consideration
and it has to be a balancing process but
there's been limited argument point of
view put forward while this is the only
option or why this level of development
is required um and as i always say um
we have to take into account what is
said by personal public speakers
because it hasn't been validated and i
think um the
comments by the parish and went much
further
than what we have been informed by the
lpa so um
i think they those comments on certain
points of personal circumstances
should be given appropriate way because
of that reason thank you
thank you uh right now i have this
counselor
thank you chairman uh yeah i have utmost
empathy for
the family and for the eloquent case
that's been put by the parish councillor
however as the officers have stipulated
there hasn't really been enough evidence
as to why
this particular type of building needs
to be produced and there could be
better alternatives rather than this
incongruous
very large uh detached garage
that's being built in front of the house
which would have an effect on the street
scene
where if you look at the house you look
at what's there already
there is already a single story
extension of the side of the house
so there was a need for further
accommodation
why could that not be built on um or
to go out of the rear of the property
rather than plonking a
big great uh detached garage in front of
the house
so i'm with the officers okay thank you
and anybody else no i think uh
councillor morley is the other world
member not obligatory because i'm
offering
no i'm fine thank you very much okay
thank you um
i actually i know the area very well
obviously as the board member but i've
not in the last 40 years but i've lived
in golden room talking for chunks of my
life and cycled and ridden up and down
that lane
no end of times in one day um
it's actually not as obtrusive as you
would think simply because of
where it is it's a little huge single
track lane
um it's almost at the end of those
houses so people accessing that row of
houses
with the exception of one that don't go
that far
um i assume the reason for the room over
the garage is it's the only way you can
park underneath you know
you still have the parking at the front
i do hear the reasons against but i
think with the right materials
i think this would this could be
appropriate and
i think the personal difficulties the
personal circumstances do
sound very considerable to me
this is more than one thing this is this
is multiple
problems and issues that the residents
are having to deal with
and so you can sorry chairman just like
to clarity
that's not what the lpa is in front of
it as
part of the submission so you i would
advise you not to take into account
things that have not been submitted to
lpa for consideration
okay right okay
i think on the old design and
appearance and impact on the countryside
i actually
think i don't think there's as much harm
as the officers do that's my view
counselor miss white
um thank you moan chairman i have to say
i don't actually have a problem with
this application at all i know the site
and i know the road i don't know
the applicants um i don't actually have
a
problem with it so um you know i'm
mindful
to um approve the application
okay right well we've had a couple of
speakers for a couple
again so i think we need to take a vote
on the officer's
recommendation um which is to refuse
bird could we go through the role please
yes of course chairman thank you members
uh so this is voting for the officer's
recommendation and if you could indicate
fought against abstaining please
starting with councillor durham
i support the officer's recommendation
thank you
thank you very much council mrs fleming
apologies chairman i'm cancer jarvis
um he's with a heavy heart but i'm
before the application based on what mr
lee's taught me over the years
thank you so you're against your
recommendation okay
keys no sorry i think council javascript
is recommendation sorry apologies i
think he was
yeah yeah for the officer's
recommendation
for this is okay that's the keys please
i'm against the officer's recommendation
councillor morley
against you councillor
four thank you councillor mrs thompson
against bit reluctantly chancellor miss
white
against i mean the results of that are
three
four four against and no extensions
thank you i mean i say reluctantly
because i i
very rarely go against the officers but
it's just a question of balance and i
don't agree here
so um i suppose i may so if you don't
mind me making a proposal from the chair
members
um i'm gonna propose that we
do accept it um the reasons being
um i don't quite agree with the
officer's view
um of the impact on um
will be the countryside the look the
street scene i i
don't believe the impact is is
going to cause any significant damage
but i don't
think we should have conditions i mean i
i think the plans actually
show um appropriate um matching
materials but i think we will have
approval of materials down as a
condition and anything else needs to be
recommended
i will second that thank you
chairman the conditions i'd suggest
would be
plans time materials as always
conditions in relation to annex the
standard conditions and that the garage
is to be retained
for car parking and incidental use
thank you chairman silly thank you
thank you so we have a proposal purely
seconded
um can we take a work please mr third
thank you challenges members
so this is voting for approval as
outlined by the chairman
and if you could indicate four against
rob stone please starting with
councillor
darwin please abstain please thank you
councillor
jarvis
yeah i'll abstain thank you tara you
counselor keys
for you councillor morley
paul chancellor against
thank you council mrs thompson
paul and council miss white
as the results of that are four four one
against and two abstentions
thank you chairman thank you thank you
very much
members uh right the
right next one building at the old dairy
broad street green
uh
[Music]
chairman um all i would say was that
i know we went through the
um items as or presented it as one
the matters that seem to be discussed
were around
the actual planning permission rather
than the listed building
consent um obviously
as members were aware the list of
building center only looks at the
list of building issues it covers
matters that would go beyond a planning
application
in relation to matters such as internal
works etc
but obviously doesn't look at any of the
um issues such as
overlooking i don't know car parking
requirements etc
um right so
yeah so the only thing i would be able
to say that would time
the members debated really would be the
whether or not it's
the optimum viable use um was
for the proposals and that was still
full within the list of building consent
but as the committee well where you know
there have been times when we've
approved listed building since while
refusing planning permission and vice
versa
because they do look at different
matters so but from the debate the only
issue that really was discussed about
the lbc
would have been about the optimum viable
use thank you chairman
right thank you um so members i'm afraid
we do have to go back and vote on
that and again from the chair i'm going
to put a proposal that we
refuse the list of building consent on
the aspect of optimum viable use which i
don't believe this
is personally is that seconded
does any member have a desperate need to
speak or could we please go to the vote
okay that sounds like you know what i do
apologize would you mind just uh
capturing for me again summarizing
what we're actually voting on there
right sorry this is about
listed building consent which as as mr
lee was saying
is it's actually about the work on the
building
nothing else associated with it nothing
to do with
um any kind of immunity or
car parking or any of those things this
is strictly about
the work on the building and as he said
i don't think we have
recently but it is quite possible to
give listed building consent but not
planning consent
but not planning permission or or vice
versa because you might think well the
planning commission's fine but
not the damage to the heritage of the
building or
vice versa the work on the building
would be fine um but it's inappropriate
to have
this use in this position whatever um
and my proposal is that
i think it the listed building consent
should be also refused because i think
we haven't looked at the potential the
optimal use of the building would be as
the barn it was built as in the first
place if that
could be managed and therefore i think
this application for the listed building
consent is for sub-optimal
use and i think it could be better used
sorry am i making any sense at all
yeah no thank you chairman yeah thank
you that was that was
that was good if you could if you could
sum up what recommendation we're being
asked to vote on as well
right well it's my i'm making a proposal
because the recommendation was
to accept it but then we didn't we
didn't approve
both recommendations so having refused
the
planning consent and one of my reasons
for refusing the planning consent was
the fact that this i don't believe this
is the optimal
use of the building and so i would
refuse
the listed building consent for the same
reasons because i think
it could be better used as a bomb which
is what is meant to be a buyer
so that's my proposal and it works so
the proposal is refusal yeah
my proposal is confusing yes i'm sorry
if i'm making this overly complicated
please bear with me i've
i'm not feeling up to power i've had
some rather bad news this week now i'm
trying to keep my head together um
right miss burke could we go to a vote
please so that was i believe seconded by
councillor keith it was second digital
did i make sense
did you get my yes so members this is in
relation to the listing building consent
for the bohan's bar at church street
tullesbury and the proposal is refusal
subject to the to the reasons relating
to them not being optimal news of the
building
and so uh starting with cancer durham
please if you could indicate four
against rob staining thank you
i agree that uh proposal thank you thank
you very much councillor jarvis
four thank you councillor keys
uh four thank you councillor morley
four thank you councillor against
thank you council mrs thompson
and councillor miss white
oops thank you very much so chairman the
results of that are 641 against and no
abstentions thank you very much
thank you so that listed building
consent is um
also refused right
um building at the old dairy broad
street green great cotton
um
oh we don't have speakers on this one
okay i believe this is parker hayes
to present the report thank you
thank you chairman
outline planning permission is sought
for the principle of the replacement of
a commercial building with up to three
dwellings
there is a verbal update for this
application at 4 pm today a signed legal
agreement was provided
to seek to overcome the suggested reason
for refusal
in relation to the third reason for
refusal sorry however proof of payment
for the check-in fee was not provided
and therefore we are
unable to confirm that this is
satisfactory and therefore
suggested reason for refusal number
three remains
this is the location plan
this is the plan
these are the existing elevations
and the existing floor plan and here are
some photographs of the site
it should be noted that the existing
site has a lawful b1 use
an extend extensive planning history
where the owner has sought to gain
permission for the use of the site for
residential purposes
four of these applications have been
dismissed at appeal and whilst the
developments proposed are materially
different to that of the current
application
three out of the four appeals have been
dismissed on the grounds that the
developments would result in an
unacceptable loss of employment land
this application would result in the
unjustified loss of employment land and
have a detrimental impact on the
character and appearance of the
surrounding area
the development would result in an
incongruous brain of development and
would not make an overly positive
contribution in terms of social
or economic sustainability therefore the
proposal was unacceptable and contrary
to the content of national and local
planning policies and therefore is
recommended for refusal
thank you chairman thank you
again i just checked this but there is
no one to speak
remember no public participation i mean
okay there is no public participation
right thank you i'm
finally leaving anybody else again um
council
please i believe you called this one in
so would you like to start us off
yes you did thank you would you like to
start us off yes yeah
it's not a problem here i've got a few
things but i'd like to hear what other
members
think as well now i think that has been
history on this site as we all know
i think this is the best application
that has come before us
is brownfield there is would be
less vehicles going in there or smaller
vehicles which we have had
just down the road i know it is on a
better road i understand that
but it would be cars rather than lorries
going in there
we need two bedrooms whether we can
argue to have the two bedrooms where we
can put that into a
claws on it they say it's unsustainable
yet
we all know or majority of us know there
was a pub just across the road
the crown which was built on i don't
know was that 15 years ago 20 years ago
now perhaps
that might have been done and
yeah i think this is not bad it's got
good
public access uh public transport you
know the
runs right by there i'd be open to
listen to what my
colleagues have to say please on this
but i think the other
the other applications that were put in
or certainly not as good
in my opinion as what this one does okay
thank you thank you very much councillor
he's right i have council morley next
[Music]
um yes just to go back what counselor
keith is saying i i remember the pub
in fact that's why i proposed many moons
ago but
it's it does seem to be i mean i'm not
an expert
it does seem to be in the area where all
houses are being
currently built and where future ones
are going to be built so
it does seem to be in the
sort of closed area of housing so i just
can't see a problem with it but i don't
know what my other colleagues think
thank you thank you councillor jarvis
thanks chairman um it does it from a
location point of view
it it does look as if it's um fairly
nearby
other housing estates so i did see
comments about it sort of harm to the
countryside
i know some of those photos do make it
look like it's in
in in the countryside and and therefore
would would cause significant harm but
i think uh um i'm pretty sure i know
wherever it is
and there's quite a few um quite a few
housing estates nearby
uh uh unless i've got the wrong location
i don't think i have
swift's i think is a housing estate
nearby um
so i would like the officer perhaps just
to clarify that in terms of
nearby housing estates because that
might affect people's uh
weight they're giving to harm to the
countryside i think the other thing is
just
in terms of um uh is is loss of
employment is that an issue that's been
raised
and i just wondered if we if anybody's
got any details on that you know when
was it last used
um you know what what how many people
are we talking about
if it hasn't actually been used for a
decade for example
and obviously it's questionable how much
weight you'd give to the loss of
employment issue and again
obviously might be happy to comment on
that thank you chairman those two points
thank you um mr lee would you like to
help us with those
yep happy to unless does any members
want to raise anything else and
okay well i've got council and i have
councillor white
and i have me thank you so council of
civil then if you're going to do this in
one hit
okay thank you chairman uh
this is interesting an interesting
location uh i don't
really see how the officers can say that
it's going to have
a visual impact on the countryside
because the buildings at the moment are
far more
incongruous with the countryside than
three new houses would be
uh it is a brownfield site i'm not sure
how long it's been occupied it has been
for
quite a while it is right next to other
residential houses so
it's part of or connected into sort of a
small ribbon
development of houses that comes off
broad street green
right near next to it just to the south
of it
and then there are houses opposite as
well so
it already is in an area and also
the council you know it is sort of would
yeah the hayward's garden village is is
going to be
very close by so it's a it's an
interesting one
in terms of of whether you know what we
should do about
it i'm still in i'm quite open-minded
thank you councillor um counseling is
right
uh thank you madam chairman um i think
uh
my i think we've refused this this has
been to appeal at two sorry commit to me
before and i think we've um refused it
when was the last i wasn't when the last
time it was
refused appeal because for me we now
don't have a five-year land supply
and and it is a brownfield site it's a
recognized brownfield site so i don't
quite see
how a refusal would stack up a appeal
and i think for me
bearing as we are where we are i think
that the
um the position of the application has
changed
um so i actually from i think we've
previously refused it i'm actually
okay with it now because because of
where we are because of policy and where
we are now
okay um right martin
um i actually don't have a problem with
it becoming houses so much as i have a
problem with the loss of employment land
given
before we just turned down a begging
business park
and this is infinitely more accessible
and
i don't know about the marketing or when
it was last year so i'm going to come to
mr lee on that because i just can't
juggle it
with the papers and find things that
will quite like you can in the chamber
um and given that there is going to be
more housing around it perhaps there
will be a future not only a use as an
employment site but actually a need for
an employment site that's
so readily accessible so
that's my thought mr lee can you um
run through all those answers for us
please i'll do my best chairman thank
you
um firstly i just also like to ray's
point on relation to
uh councillor keith's statement about
him considering this is the best
application that's come before
us all the previous applications been
refused so
it shouldn't be a case of just because
it's the best it must automatically be
acceptable there is still a policy
requirement to meet a threshold so i'd
just obviously like to make that
clear um
it is a brownfield site um
government guidance relation to
brownfield sites and
them is within settlement boundaries and
this site isn't within the settlement
boundary so i think something that
becomes a bit of a moot point
um obviously it is a consideration and
we do allow the loss of employment land
um our policy accepts that if it's
evidenced
one of the key aspects is to show it's
been marketed um
and the obvious report goes through
different aspects but in relation to a
couple of points raised by members
to actually currently the site is
actually in use
so um it is actually in use at the
moment
um i think there may be some confusion
by members
in relation to the reason refuse there's
no actual reason for using relation to
sustainability or accessibility per se
so we are accepting there is public
transport and that hasn't formed a
refusal
in any of the previous applications and
isn't part of this um
applications recommendations so the fact
that there may be public transport you
know that's why we put there's other
housing around
etc hasn't formed part of this reason
fuse or
or any of the others um
what i would say though in relation to
council's point in rel
about the impact on the character of the
area for one of the better phrase
this is something that has been
discussed by inspectors previously and
found to be unacceptable
it's not considered the proposed
residential accommodation this location
would follow the pattern of development
and the existing buildings i don't think
anyone's trying to argue of any
particular architectural merit or
something that needs to be retained but
they are
of a nature that you'd maybe find in a
semi-rural area
they are sort of buildings that you
expect
facilitate a transition into the
countryside and inspectors have looked
at that
and found that actually these buildings
being on site is preferable in design
terms
than provision of residential dwellings
which would significantly alter the
rural character the area
and also would have a an extension of
the lifetime of the development on this
site you know
members when we make decisions we need
to consider a lifetime development
obviously
certain buildings come certain buildings
go obviously providing a new
permission on site and then having that
built out extends obviously the life of
building
you know something debated before
committee so i won't bother to
heavily carry on with that point um in
relation to councillor white's point
um my understanding is that actually i
think this might be
out the four appeals that where the
inspectors dismissed residential housing
on this site three out of four we were
unable to demonstrate a five-year land
supply at that time
so um i think that is a very very
significant material consideration when
looking at this
application is that actually previously
when we were unable to demonstrate
fabian land supply
inspectors have still found this site
should not be a site
used for a residential accommodation
both based both on a lot of employment
land and also the urban grain
relationship with
the street scene etc and maybe a bit
more clarity
on the layout aspect so
um i acknowledge we need housing to a
certain extent we are only
point one of a year short though so it's
not a case of we need to accept every
application this scheme
has been looked at by an inspector or
not this scheme per se but similar
schemes you know
the principle of residential
accommodation on this site has been
attacked by inspectors and been found to
be
unacceptable and
those were times we didn't have five and
a half plus so i think those decisions
really do need to be a given appropriate
way
in the termination this application
thank you chairman
thank you um i have done it again i
haven't put the recommendation
so i'm going to do that now without
further ado that doesn't mean you can't
speak afterwards if you
need to um the recommendation is in fact
it refused for the reasons detailed in
section 8 of the report
um is there a second look at that i'll
second that
chairman okay thank you councillor um
actually i think most people have said
what they
need to say is is there anyone who would
like to come back on
anything
oh yes i'd just like to come back on
that um
we've just um had an industrial state
we've turned down an extension of
industrial state because of houses
around it
yet the district council say that
there's
might be a need for work when we build
more houses around it so i
don't really quite see where we're
coming from with that you know
because industrial and houses don't go
together with the noise in the car park
in which we just turned down yet we say
this place
is okay so that's just one thing i'd
like to say
and the other it was a personal thing i
think this
application was better whether other
applications have been put in i think
this was the better one of what i've
seen
since i've been a councillor on the site
and as
councillor jarvis said what i said there
was poplar grove which is right next
door to the place
and there was houses built down there
over there since i've been a district
council over the last five years we've
added houses down that and that is an
unmade track
thank you that's all i'd like to say
thank you um
i'm sure mr lee will put me right if i'm
wrong but b1 is office
and very like use it is the kind of
thing you can in fact
um do you know as an ancillary business
in
in your own home in in a you know slap
bang in the middle of a housing estate
am i right there mr wing
yeah be a chairman basically be one is
development you could have it joining a
household without causing any issue yet
right so you know we're not mixing this
with any kind of
industry or or um
warehousing or anything like that so
it's not the same
ballpark at all as um business plan
yeah that's correct although what we
were saying was
that was mostly v1 wasn't it then all
this used but um
nevertheless the transport system and so
many other things are very different
here plus
it's in use therefore we need it
that's my view um if
there's no one else to speak
um i think yes let's put recommendation
to the vote so please
thank you chairman members and this is a
vote for
um refusal as per the officer's
recommendation if you could just
indicate if you're fought against or
abstaining when i call your name
starting with council durham please
on fine balance i vote in favor of the
officer recommendation thank you very
much
councillor jarvis
i think on balance i'm against the
officer's recommendation
thank you tara thank you councillor keys
i'm against the officer's recommendation
counselor morley
against thank you councillor
i'm for the officer's recommendation
thank you council mrs thompson
and for the officer's recommendation
much and council miss white
against the results of that are three
four four against and no abstentions
thank you very much
okay thank you well well that
recommendation
falls so we need a proposal um which i'm
going to assume is
to um to approve it and can someone come
up with one please
don't all speak at once uh yeah there we
are i've
got a few ideas here i've got h4
h1 t1 good public
sorry chairman i thought just before
counselor keys carries on
you need to talk to the reasons for
refusal um just
quoting policy numbers isn't going to be
assist yet you have to
either talk to reason fews or highlight
where the benefits outweigh the harm
i hadn't finished but i will take your
points mr lee
well that is the simpler way of dealing
with it so the
so it's altering the character of the
area uh
loss of employment and we actually
haven't got the legal agreement sorted
although we thought we had it turned out
we haven't
so chairman obviously need to highlight
the planning history of the site as well
in any while
these what's changed to overcome the
harm that inspectors have found
previously as well
right okay um council of jarvis would
like to speak um
is that okay with you councillor keys it
might give you a bit more
yeah i think um councillor jarvis is
definitely more educated on me and i
think
he'll be able to speak a bit better but
i might be able to help him or help him
and others with some other bits that i
have broke down here but
whether that's stan okay of jarvis
yeah i mean i think um if i understand
um
the situation we're incorrectly we're
trying to come up with reasons
for for approval is that correct well it
is but it's reasons
for approval that address the reasons
for refusal that were given in the
report
so um also as mr lee said
um the previous planning history where
they keep turning down what we're about
to propose
that we do okay i mean i think we're
probably going to need um
uh matli's helping this but um
i i i don't think it seems to me on
balance that it causes a harm to the
countryside it's a brownfield
site and
there is obviously we've we've heard
mention of the need
the housing housing supply which we're
now short of
this is three properties loss of
employment
issue i mean i'm not sure
you know i don't there might be one man
in his dog or one lady in her dog
um dealing with kitchen bits i i haven't
heard any facts about how many people
work there
um but um if the employment issue it
sounded like that was a
concern um uh you know that perhaps you
don't have enough information on that
but i'd be led to believe that um
that that it wasn't being used but uh
perhaps obviously knows more about it
than than we do
definitely confirmed chairman yeah well
would that be i don't
chairman sorry through you i mean you
know if if one person is using it or two
people is that that that
constitutes being used and for
employment purposes
um but you know um so um
okay so i think in terms of
an alternative potential you know it
could potentially
accommodate a lot more workers just
depending on what's being carried out
it's obviously slightly slightly odd
isn't it because obviously the person
that owns it clearly doesn't see it as
being a good place to
to to use as a business otherwise they
wouldn't be planning to build properties
there
but um uh i think uh yeah i mean
the issue i mentioned brownfield site
and no detrimental harm to the
countryside because it's surrounded by
other residential areas
would be um the points i'd try and
include
um hopefully as reasons for approval
i don't know if matt lee can assist on
that
um dude chairman obviously i've
discussed before you know
reasons for approval the case was clear
that this has to be member-led it's not
you know like with reasons of views i'm
happy to
but um the big issue i've got is that
the point you've just talked about about
properties being accepted has been found
to be unacceptable by an inspector
um and i've not heard any debate around
why this benefits outweigh the harm it's
particularly taken to count that three
of the previous four
refusals were when we're actually able
to demonstrate a much lower
five-year land supply figure so the
benefits of the dwellings
is minimal taking to cut the planning
history you know i think the big issue
with this application is the planning
issue that's been refused previously by
inspectors you know it's
very challenging to put forward
i'm just struggling to see any real
material considerations or differences
between the previous applications and
now
that would help me assist members in
coming to a reason for approval
and obviously i have to give my
professional opinion so it's very
difficult
in this instance you know take into
account the planning history which
i'm not convinced maybe given the level
of weight that i would
recommend it should be thank you
chairman
and the brownfield site has much less
weight because it isn't within
the settlement boundary sort of
presumption doesn't apply does it mister
no and also obviously points council
jarvis raised
the final point didn't really cover the
loss of the employment which
our policy doesn't really care for one
of the better phrases whether it's one
or a hundred people because
the whole and you've got to remember
that i think it's something like 80
of the enterprises within the district
are
sma small and medium enterprises so the
actual fact is that small
units are exactly what we do need we
don't need large ones and
you know reason we support them
throughout the district is it supports
various different commercial and
employment opportunities through the
district rather than just having
large purpose-built ones for example in
haybridge or malden or
burnham or et cetera which only would
only be useful to maybe
not the full extent of the district
thank you
thank you while you digest that jarvis
can i
um council white wants to come back
thank you
um thank you ma'am chairman i mean i'm
i'm
one of the reasons i had an about face
on this one
was because of the um it changing
character of the surrounding areas
at previous appeals it was more rural
and there was less housing but as the
years passed
the area has got more built up and
therefore i
i see no problem with the um reuse of
the buildings
thank you i think council drivers might
find that very helpful
or not council council keys
uh what about the site would have
greater benefit to the local community
if an alternative use was permitted
got that i'm just looking through the
book now
present activity on the site
significantly harms the character and
amenity of the adjacent area
use that loosely as such i think
you're struggling with that because it's
well it's not
it's not a nice looking industrial area
so i think that could
does hound the character i think your
house would look better that's my
personal view
anybody else looking into australia
well do look better than others you know
this looks better than an asbestos one
and vice versa you know the chairman my
advice would be that members shouldn't
be looking at
the local plan now to come up with their
argument for why they uh not supporting
application that should have been
something that was clearly
vocalized during the debate um i
can't i realized the time mr lee and i
was
looking at it i've got the page open you
know i'm not
clued up in a planner but i've got bits
and pieces in front of me which we've
been given to use
well obviously what i would highlight
also in relation to the greater benefits
if an alternative use was permitted
um you know our policy allows for that
we haven't
you know we've argued in the report that
that hasn't been and there's the
planning issue that's found that
retaining employment use
has a i've said this is the challenging
point is that inspectors have challenges
and looked at this so it's very hard for
me to give any advice that would
really because there is to my knowledge
there are no real new material situation
since previous decisions
so obviously at the end of the day it's
in the gift of the members but it's very
hard to give any
clear advice that would be any help to
members
right counselor jarvis thank you for
that
yeah yes yes i was hoping to get some
guidance from officer lee
um but i do not when he doesn't agree
i understand i think councillor white if
i may say i think she really
probably is helping us come up with the
the best reason
but that is different now um to perhaps
a pre-previous
application so that the area is just
more developed
and therefore um i think there is less
harm to the countryside i wonder if we
could build on that because
clearly if if it's in a rural setting
uh then it can't there can be harm to
the countryside but if there are lots of
um
other housing estates nearby which
perhaps there weren't on previous okay
applications i'm afraid i don't have
that knowledge um but perhaps that
other councils will have that and that
could be um
could be uh uh part of our reason for um
for approving okay
um right i have got councillor but you
know what we shouldn't be doing is
debating a whole bunch of reasons
for approval at this stage given that we
didn't talk about them earlier
um please uh so i'm actually going to
yeah back up what the officers are
saying
yeah there aren't any new houses in that
vicinity
at the moment so there isn't any new
houses in terms of that location and
part of that
part of that broad street green area so
the new houses are probably half a mile
away or so so you can't really use that
as an excuse
um or or a reason um
so i i really think that that reasoning
is extremely weak and
and yeah and i would say often what the
officers say to us is dangerous
uh in terms of using that as as a as a
reasoning so
um i really don't think the members
uh are thinking about this in the in the
right way on this particular
uh situation thank you moving quickly on
to i think that's councillor durham it's
confusing that you come up as cece
just started to thank councillor siddal
there chairman
it is me it is me um thank you
um yes we yet again
we've got ourselves in a little bit of a
pickle haven't we um
and um you know we are
we are straining ourselves for thinking
of reasons to
um grant this that aren't going to get
us in trouble at a later date
and i fear we're i'm very the thinnest
of thin ice so i'll support councillor
ziddle and
and i'd really like to get this wrapped
up we've already been two and a half
hours chairman
we are only two horribly aware
councilman thank you
since i've really done before and i
don't offend any members if i do
so make this suggestion is that okay go
for it please
i'm just quite concerned you know we
seem to be
bringing a lot of discussion that wasn't
in the debate previously
um and some of the points have been made
about whether or not there has been any
new development within the area since
the previous permissions and some
members have said there is and some
members have said that haven't
see that information hasn't been
provided to the committee
so i'm reluctant for members to really
be based members
aren't 100 sure of it to be based in
their opinion on either um
so whether it might help if this is some
of the thought process of what some of
the members have had
against their objection to the previous
for the office of objection
so the officer's recommendation was that
we could defer the item
to the next committee with a report as
bringing back that would
explain what has or hasn't been approved
around the site since the previous
application does that get into trouble
for non-determinant does that get us in
any difficulty with non-determination
the application applicant would have the
right to appeal or non-determination
the application is up for refusal now so
it wouldn't be a risk and i wouldn't say
it was in the applicant's
best interest to appeal now
and has to wait however many months
rather than
wait in a month to see whether or not
members agreed or didn't agree with the
opera's recommendation but
i'm conscious that we we can't be
bringing new information into the reason
for approval
um so i would just consider that
potentially
that might be an option to at least be
able to re-stimulate the debate maybe
next time with more information
thank you i think that may be very
helpful um
councillor miss white um
we've only determined it in so far as
yes
we didn't accept the officer's
recommendation to refuse
um on the other hand as councillor
durham has pointed out that this
increasingly laid out we are in a pickle
because
we're finding i'm saying we as a
committee are finding difficulty
addressing
the reasons for refusal that we didn't
like
um miss bird can you help us on this
where we are as regards the constitution
can we now defer it for more information
well gentlemen um i wouldn't like to be
definite but
obviously members have voted on the
officer's recommendation to
be um to refuse it
um and so now they need to determine the
application if that determination
is felt not to be possible then as ma if
the officer's advised
that members may consider deferral and i
would have thought that would be okay
but we made it chairman i'm i'm happy to
propose that it's deferred for further
information
if anybody seconds that very much
counseling
second day um that seconded
that was i believe councillor yeah it
was yes
sounded like your voice yes right
members can we please vote on a deferral
so we get more information
on what is here now wasn't here at the
last
um appeal um
yeah miss burke can we have a roll call
please
yes chairman so members is deferring for
further information
to be brought back to the next meeting
and if you could indicate four against
rob stain starting with councillor
darwin please
i i vote in favor of deferring thank you
thank you very much councillor jarvis
i'm against that because i feel we've
already decided we should be voting
whether we approve it or not
but understanding we're having some
difficulties
thank you councillor keys yeah i'm the
same as councillor
um jarvis yeah i'm the kings
thank you cancer morley against
think he counts mrs thompson
or he's right
council miss white
how many did we have again uh moments
three
four three against oh there's cancer
sorry and i don't know what to do about
this because i can see we don't have any
reasons necessarily to approve it but
constitutionally i feel that we've
already voted so i'm in a really
difficult position on this one i
i it's sort of unprecedented really
and well we have been here before
we're just gonna have to
we're gonna have to come up with some
reasons for approval that
may or may not satisfy what we should
have been
doing and you know i i chairman i
i'm obviously responsible but if members
are gonna vote for something they can't
then justify doing the opposite i'm i'm
in your hands members
i would just suggest that in relation to
the constitution obviously
all that's happened so far is that the
officer's recommendation has not been
agreed there is no the application
hasn't been
approved on that it hasn't been
determined um
if any members have concerns about their
ability to make an informed judgment
for example where councillor jarvis
raised an earlier issue about
the level of employment you know he said
he had concerns about lack of
information on that and
my advice always would be you should
fall on the
pragmatic side in that respect rather
than and policy side rather than against
but that's thing but if members
don't feel they have information we can
bring that to them
it wouldn't be the first time i've
suggested such such a uh
approach in a committee in relation to
deferring if there is additional
information sought by committee
and thank chairman thank you right so
we're just waiting for your
vote council yeah but my problem is that
we've already voted against the
officer's recommendation and i just
think con
for me constitutionally i don't know how
i can
effectively do an about turn because if
we divert it could be an event
about 10 so i'm i'm i i only see for the
first time in my life i don't know what
to do on this one
i i i think
i i think i'm going to have to go
against the recommendation i i
only because i voted against the
officer's recommendation i just don't i
don't see how i can
change it i'm just i'm really i'm it's
your decision counselor
that's what you're saying yeah i'm
completely blown away by this
it's just something we've not come
across before yeah
okay well we've been here before with
when members have been very keen to do
you know disagree with the officer's
recommendation and then we don't
have any reasons to do the other thing
right well that sounds to me like the
turtle failed
so come on members it's tentative
yeah well we've got that far but what
are the reasons
activity activity um significantly harms
the character and immunity of the
adjacent area
that's one
well you can say i mean i can't are you
members you can say whatever you
want you've got housing it's got through
you chairman it's got houses around it
and i think
industrial roundhouses is a no-go we've
already had it
it's not industrial it's not industrial
it's b1
and it's never been allowed to have
houses there before well
and that's not a reason to approve house
the house has been developed
yeah but it had lauren's going in before
when it was a dairy which is still
classed as a dairy
and it had loads of milk floats right
over there and that would significantly
harm the area
which you could go back to that's not a
reason for approval
that's still not being won and it's not
a reason for refusal
i appreciate it
some clarification on the location um on
the location plan
is solely the commercial building and
the entrance to the access that is
outlined in red
the outline in blue will still remain as
a commercial use
so there will be the provision of up to
three dwellings amongst an existing
commercial use on that site
the whole site will not change to
residential as part of this application
oh yes thank you very very much
that makes it even worse
counselor jobs
yes thanks for that additional
information there um
which we probably should have spotted
but uh i think are we looking i'm
happy first of all to second councillor
key's recommendation of approval
and um i think it's uh isn't there
aren't we isn't there a sort of
presumption naturally in the favor of uh
residential building residential
properties um
and if that's the case um i can't see
you know that this site you know sort of
does any harm with other
other properties in the near vicinity
and it's a brownfield site i mean
isn't that it isn't that enough for us
to to agree
uh i know obviously it doesn't feel so
but
i mean that's what we're saying uh
whether that's strong enough or not
that is what you're saying um the reason
that you can't really second a proposal
that doesn't have the reasons for
approval yet
so um we're still at that stage um
it is still going to be housing with b1
use nearby
which um actually say that um we should
have all spotted that
especially me but anyway uh thank you
very much mrs parker
for that um and it's loss of an
employment site this isn't uh you know a
patch of
you know uh waste wasteland with rubbish
all over it this
is an employment site where there is
someone
working but you know if if members want
to say
look we think that having the houses
here outweighs
the employment use then within your gift
to say it
just sorry one point that counselor
jarvis just said there is no presumption
of
building houses no there's no assumption
in favor of that approach so
that can't be a consideration
sustainable development yes but it's
sustainable employment land now
and case law is clear that sustainable
development is what the ldp says and the
ldp says
we should protect employment land so
that would be
what the sustainable development so the
point is we need to be looking at
this isn't you know this application is
in conflict with policy in conflict with
previous inspectors decisions you really
need to be looking at material
considerations the way in favor of it
that's the only approach really i can
give members advice to looking
so for a reason for approval um as
always as you said self-chairman it's in
the gift of the committee to give it as
they see
but obviously this one used again
of course i've got councillor darren
um i'm having a sense of humor failure
i'm hoping you can retrieve something
here for me councillor
always had a legacy no joy here i'm
afraid can we just please move on well
yes but where to
i think we should defer it
or you can approve it with reasons that
just open the floodgates to everybody
everybody everywhere
just like we keep dealing with lots of
things really
[Music]
well i've maybe might
i know you have but you haven't vote we
can't vote without the reasons for
approval
and the reasons for approval seem to me
to be
that members feel the loss of the
employment
site is less important than the gain of
three houses now i think you'll regret
that if we say that
but that is what you're saying yes
[Music]
that's it in a nutshell isn't it mr lee
yes chairman thank you yeah i thought it
was
okay that's your reason for approval
council
please we'll get both on it
and chairman can i just clarify exactly
what the reason for refusal is that
we're listing
please so a reason for people don't
apologize
i know just um
well what i just said and nobody
disagreed with me
although i don't agree with it is that
the
gain of the three dwellings outweighs
the loss of the employment
land that's that's what people are
saying
that's what members are saying i don't
agree with it
[Music]
unless anyone's going to come up with a
different reason for approval
um i think we better let this bill take
the vote
uh okay members so um this is voting for
approval
and as for the reason outlined just by
chairman um if you could indicate
sorry but uh with conditions i'd suggest
that they in this instance would be uh
delegated to officers uh with the
consultation with chairman and the world
members
because it's quite a complex
multi-layered application yeah well done
mr lee thank you
thank you i'm so sorry i'm so starting
with cancer durham please
can you just reconfirm what this vote is
about because yeah
and the reason for approval was that the
gain of three dwellings
outweighed the loss of employment
no i don't agree and i think this is
probably the worst of a load of bad
mistakes that we've made thank you
thank you that's the uh jarvis please
i'm approving on that basis you're
agreeing okay thank you
councillor keys i agree on that basis
[Music]
agreed
i think i've completely lost the plot
this evening but i think because of
where we are it's going to have to be um
for real absolutely thank you so
chairman the results of that are four
in favor three against and no
abstentions thank you very much
thank you well that goes ahead with that
those reasons for approval um
land rear of hill barn rectory lane
has been withdrawn so now we're looking
at thirty's malden road tip tree
uh yes which was called in by councillor
siddal i believe that's um
that's your award isn't it that's cotton
yes
um back to my prom correct yes
[Music]
um right could we have the presentation
please
mr haines i believe this is counting
thank you chairman planning permission
is sought for the construction of a
two-story rear extension
this is the location plan this is the
block plan
these are the existing elevations
these are the proposed elevations
these are the existing floor and roof
plan
these the proposed floor plans
and here are some photographs of the
site it should be noted that the
original permission for this property is
subject to a condition that the
occupants of the dwelling are
agricultural workers
planning permission for this new
dwelling in a rural area would have
exceptionally been granted on the basis
that there was a need for a farm worker
to live on the site to meet the needs of
the farm holding
policy h7 of the ldp relates
specifically to agricultural workers
accommodation and seeks to ensure that
the proposed development in this
instance extension is commensurate with
the
needs of the agricultural enterprise it
is acknowledged that the countryside can
only accommodate limited forms of
development and it is generally accepted
that development in the open countryside
should be strictly controlled
however it is also accepted that at
times the specific needs of a farming
enterprise may make it essential to live
at or
very close to the enterprise and
therefore each case will depend on the
needs of the enterprise
and should not be based on the personal
preferences or circumstances of any of
the individuals
involved this involves the need to
ensure that the dwelling is of a size
and scale that is proportionate to the
needs of the enterprise rather than
meeting an aspirational want or need of
the applicant
furthermore this application is a
resubmission of the previously refused
application twenty
zero zero five two two which was refused
as it had not been demonstrated that the
size of the enlarged dwelling was
commensurate with the needs of the
agricultural enterprise
the proposed works remain unchanged as
part of this application
and additional information has been
provided to demonstrate that the
extension is commensurate with the needs
of the enterprise
this is detailed within section 5.1 of
the report
this application is recommended for
refusal as it has not been demonstrated
that the size of the enlarged dwelling
is commensurate with the needs of the
agricultural enterprise and the
development would therefore be country
policies sa and h7 thank you chairman
thank you um right we have a submission
from mr mccheney have i pronounced you
properly
hello i'm sorry i'm sorry you've been
kept waiting for very long
um please speak you have two minutes and
when you begin thank you
good evening councillors yes i have
captained red pigs at thirteries from
1984 until 2017
and i've only given this up as i was
living with my family
another address and it was completely
unrealistic to try to farm
while not living up third trees
especially when the cells were faring
down
in the early hours of the morning i
would like to lean the jewish more
livestock back onto the hole in the game
to secure its future success
therefore myself and my family need to
be living on the site
we have supplied details within our
agricultural statement
my 93 year old mother still lives at
third trees and would like to say that
there that she is needing more and more
daily care and company
and as time goes on we'll only be
needing more leaving her there on her
own at night very well
the house is needed for modern life
modernization
as the kitchen's very small see pictures
attached to the application statement
and there's only a small toilet
downstairs and one family bathroom
upstairs
the extension would incorporate a lift
to help mobility for my mother
and the separate living area and ensuite
for her independence
the officer's report states that there
are no issues with the design or size of
the extension
and there is no negative impact on the
neighbors
the extension sits within the domestic
cartilage of the property
also great for active parish council and
local residents have not raised any
objections
smallholders are a family concern and we
wanted this to continue to future
generations of our family
and there is a moral responsibility to
care for our elderly family members
alongside making
sure the needs of the small holding
business are met and this
should be considered in the fair manner
thank you
thank you very
speaker much this item um
i'm going to put the recommendation
which is to refuse i'm going to have a
second one
[Music]
don't have a second
again it doesn't oblige anyone to vote
in any particular way but it does put it
on the table
uh right i do have councillor siddal to
speak and i've noticed
councillor white so let's get in that
way
uh thank you chairman yes
the the whole thing as the applicant has
just uh described
and the evidence that they presented
this is to allow some multiple
occupancy so that the h7 policy can
continue
um and allow the owner of it and they've
been an owner of the farm since the
1980s
and also accommodate the whole family so
i would say that h7 has been
proved and therefore we should go
against officers
and approve this application thank you
yes thank you sorry i've just been
distracted we did just move the
officer's recommendation and it was
seconded
by cancer morning
[Music]
don't worry sorry that was a sorry
mystic
um right counselor was right we can
carry on please
and we have something for that thank you
madam chairman um
unlike the last application i'm really
very clear on this one
um i just the officers have got this
absolutely wrong
i think you know a lot of these farms
all have extended families that's why
farm houses are traditionally large
and i have absolutely no problem i mean
there's no problem with the
neighbours there's no problem anything
else if they want to increase it
i've got absolutely no problem at all
and i really don't understand why this
is down for refusal
well it's because of the ag tie but i
hear what you're saying uh right i've
got councillor keys
yeah great really my other two um
councillors already stole my thunder but
yeah i haven't got a problem with this
he's explained himself there i know the
place very well it's just up the road
from me but yes i haven't got any
problems with this whatsoever and i
think
i will definitely be voting against the
officers recommendation
okay thank you i've got councillor
morley
and i think councillor white might want
to come back or is that a legacy hand
but councillor morley please uh yes
thank you chair
yes i've i've known of the family an
awful long time and um
they have been farming in particular pig
farming
for as long as i can remember so i can't
say from that and obviously
with livestock you need constant care i
know that well enough being a farmer as
well still
luckily i'm one of the few left so
i'm against the officers on this
particular one thank you
thank you and councillor jarvis
thanks chairman um yeah i mean we just
heard obviously
i noticed at the end of the report it's
got reason for refusal that hasn't been
demonstrated the size of the enlarged
dwelling
is commensurate with the needs of the
agricultural enterprise but i mean we've
just heard
uh obviously on the man himself um
what he wants and what he wants to do
there and uh we've got animals too and
uh
you do need to have uh quite large
quite large areas look after lots of
different animals and i think
as councilor morley said you often have
to have them very close so you can give
good attention
so i don't really quite see that summary
from the officers
so i think i'll wait to hear other
people but i'm certainly uh
uh we would uh currently i would be
thinking that um
we should be approving this application
challenge
okay thank you it's actually because
it's the needs of the existing
youth not not the aspiration we use
however
counseling was fine
unless that was another thing yeah i
mean i mean for me
i i don't see why an agricultural tie
has to limit the size of a building if
the applicants still need a bigger
building and there's no problems if
it's not they haven't got the room or
the neighbors are upset
i don't see a problem i mean just to say
because it's agriculture you only
you know you have to have a particular
size house seems very very
unreasonable i mean very unreasonable i
can't quite get my head around this one
and use one of those evenings for that
so um no i
absolutely dead against the officer's
recommendations
okay i hear what you're saying um
i agree i think i agree with your view
on the policy but nevertheless
it is the policy and that's why
lee may well not agree with himself i'm
not going to ask him the question
you know well actually chairman i think
it's quite an interesting point what
we've got to
offer you sorry is what you've got to
remember is that
government guidance policy everything is
quite clear that
development within the countryside
should only be allowed for exceptional
circumstances and
when you allow in agricultural dwelling
that is an exceptional circumstance
is because there is a functional need
for that enterprise
and that is what you know you go back to
previous guidance before the mppf you
know this is a well-established
you know point of planning principle and
that
as the case officer explained in our
presentation you know our policy
and government guidance it relates to
the size of the enterprise it's not an
aspiration
or need it relates specifically to the
size of the enterprise and we have one
appeals in my time i can think of one
that was actually relation just
putting dormers in the roof of a
dwelling that we refused because it said
it would
increased the size of the building
without there needing to be ever
there hadn't been evidence there was no
sorry it's been a long night um
but what i would but what i would say
i'll see members you know
there is obviously subjectivity with all
these applications but in this
application i think you've got to
remember that this is not increasing the
number of bedrooms
this is just making the stand of
accommodation want a better
word improved but
you know as we discussed earlier about
special circumstances and things you
know the personal circumstances are not
really
in most instances a material
consideration and
the need is not about the applicant the
needs about the enterprise per se
because it's a relation to
the special circumstances that were
allowing agricultural dwelling
in the first place rather than the
personal circumstances of the need
but and what i'd also obviously imply
highlight is obviously
we have over the years since i've been
here
allowed a number of agricultural
dwellings to
lose their agricultural tyres because
they were very large
they were very opulent for a better
phrase and that then meant that they
were not
appropriate for agricultural dwelling in
the long term because of
people you know their average
agricultural wage is a lot lower than
the
average uh commercial wage and that
that has and that is part of the reason
is that white has to be
it relates to the enterprise rather than
the personal circumstance of the
personal wants of the applicant because
these dwellings are only allowed in
sexual circumstances and
if they do get too large or you know
they're at disproportionate
it may result in a need for us to
actually release the agricultural
condition in the future thank you
chairman
thank you mr lee i do understand
although that does rather beg the
question why aren't all agricultural
ties you know huts that only have single
people working there
you know that you have a dwelling that
just supports the number of people
you need to work not the rest of the
family however
moving on because i don't want to get
bogged down in that um
council don't oh you did want to speak
yes please counsel the government
yeah thank you very much um
yes um thank you uh there is a
a well-renowned property not far from
where i'm sitting
now that has smacks of rather the same
and it's a name that will spread fear
into the hearts of
should be members and officers and that
is meadows wood and walter
which was a great a grossly extended
um farm workers cottage that had a tie
and then of course what happened
straight after that
property was given its permission to
extend and become a five-bedroom house
um we started getting applications to
revoke the occupancy restriction
and it just caused absolute
well a lot of discontent in this village
and there is a need for agricultural
worker dwellings
absolutely um but i i just think that
this
is unfortunately another meadows
in the making and i will be supporting
the officer's recommendation
okay thank you that's a third point
right members um oh okay
yeah just just to come back yeah this
isn't a very large house currently
and the extension isn't that extensive
it is just about uh you know
going out of the rear of the property
and enabling
the uh agricultural land to be worked
effectively by the whole family and to
accommodate the whole family
so i i don't have those same concerns
okay thank you right i think we need to
vote on this one members
so um we have moved the recommendation
which in this case is to
refuse so could we take the vote please
thank you chairman
and members voting against the officer's
recommendation refusal
if you could indicate fought against or
abstaining
oh you exactly that's wrong sorry miss
bird i'm with you in my head i'm with
you
we are voting on the officer's
recommendation to refuse
that's what i said jen that's not what
we heard
oh sorry that's what i thought i'd read
out sorry apologies if i didn't say that
officer's recommendation of refusal yes
absolutely
we're voting on that i thought you said
we were voting against it but never mind
carry on
sorry jim i'm voting in favor of the
officer's recommendation
thank you
this please yeah i'm against the
officer's recommendation
thank you cancer keys i am against the
officer's recommendation
counselor morley against two
councillors against thank you council
mrs thompson
i'm going to understand
so the results of that are one in favor
of five against and one abstaining
thank you right council signal i'm
looking for you
to your proposal which i'm assuming is
to approve
and with reasons for approval
that address these reasons it might be
as quick as possible and hopefully as
succinct as possible so
i i we should recommend the approval
because it has been demonstrated that
the 87 requirements have been met by the
applicant
to ensure that the agricultural land
can be worked effectively and
accommodate that need
i'll second that okay that's julie's
secondary council civil proposal duly
seconded by
council of keys does anyone feel the
need to speak given that we've had a
debate and most things should have been
said
excellent vote please miss miss bird if
you go through
thank you chairman members voting for
approval as outlined by councillor
siddal
and if you could indicate four against
rob stone please starting with
councillor durham oh hang on um
sorry we need conditions can we delegate
conditions to the offices
that's all right thank you so uh voting
for approval
and with conditions delegated to
officers for the reason outlined by
council siddal
and starting the council durham please
i will abstain thank you thank you
councillor jarvis
i'm four thank you thank you councillor
keys
i'm four please thank you councillor
morley
four tara please thank you councillor
four
thank you council mrs thompson and
thank you and counselor miss white
absolutely
four very much so chairman the results
of that are four
four nobody against and two abstentions
thank you
okay well thank you very much i'm going
to say it as quickly as i can
item 12 any other writings of business
the chairman of the committee decides
are urgent there are none
so with thanks and for the perseverance
of the officers and members thanks to
all of you for your contributions uh
i'll call a meeting
to a close at 9 15.
you know um
thank you all as the meetings now closed
members were advised not to enter into
any further
you